I'm Jenna Fisher. And I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together. And we're best friends. And now we're doing the Ultimate Office rewatch podcast just for you. Each week we will break down an episode of The Office and give exclusive behind-the-scenes stories that only two people who were there can tell you. We're The Office, ladies. Hi, lady. How's it going? It's going really great. I'm in my new podcast closet. I moved from one closet to another closet. But this is my permanent podcast closet. It's for podcasting. This is the third closet I've seen you in podcasting. Right. Because I did Casino Night from my daughter's closet. Well, let's tell everyone what we're here to talk
我是詹娜·费舍尔。我是安吉拉·金西。我们一起出演过《办公室》。而且我们是最好的朋友。现在我们专门为你制作了办公室重温播客《Ultimate Office》。每周我们都会剖析一集《办公室》，并分享只有身临其境的两个人才能告诉你的独家幕后故事。我们是办公室女士们。嗨，女士。最近怎么样？真的很好。我在我的新播客衣橱里。我从一个衣橱搬到了另一个衣橱。但这是我永久的播客衣橱。它是为了做播客准备的。这是我见过的你做播客的第三个衣橱。没错。因为我是从我女儿的衣橱里录制《赌场之夜》的。好吧，让我们告诉大家我们今天来聊什么
about today. We're talking about the episode Back from Vacation. It is season three, episode 11, written by Justin Spitzer and directed by Julian Farino. Let's hear a summary. All right. Well, in this episode, Michael returns from his all-inclusive trip to Jamaica. He is tan. He is happy. We find out who he went with. Yes, we do. Jan. Scandalous office romance. Well, despite Jan's insistence that Michael keep their vacation a secret, Michael accidentally circulates an intimate photo of them to the entire office and beyond. So, he and Dwight are going to spend this episode trying to retrieve and delete the photo while Michael awaits Jan's arrival in Scranton. Meanwhile, Angela has to throw together a last-minute
内容。我们正在讨论《度假归来》那一集。它是第三季第11集，由贾斯汀·斯皮策编剧，朱利安·法里诺导演。我们来听听剧情梗概。好的。在这集中，迈克尔结束了他在牙买加的全包度假回来了。他晒黑了。他很开心。我们发现他是和谁一起去的。是的，我们知道了。简。轰动的办公室恋情。好吧，尽管简坚持要迈克尔对他们的假期保密，但迈克尔还是不小心将一张他们的亲密照片群发给了整个办公室及以外的人。所以，他和德怀特将在这一集里试图找回并删除这张照片，而迈克尔则在斯克兰顿等待简的到来。与此同时，安吉拉不得不临时凑合办一场
luau and Pam gives Jim advice that helps his relationship with Karen. Hmm. Yeah. Let's jump into fastback number one. This episode was written by Justin Spitzer. Now, we talked a little bit about Justin before. He created the show Superstore. And remember, we found out that he's the person that wrote the twin absorption line for Dwight in grief counseling. Yes. That was the Jen Salata deep dive. And we found that out. Well, this was Justin's first full episode. So, I reached out to him because I've kept in touch with Justin since we wrapped. Justin's just one of my favorite people, I have to say. He is so lovely. So, I reached out to Justin and I asked him, where did the idea for this episode come from? And
卢奥派对，而帕姆给吉姆提出了建议，帮助改善了他和凯伦的关系。嗯。是的。让我们直接进入第一条花絮。这一集是由贾斯汀·斯皮策编剧的。现在，我们之前已经稍微聊过贾斯汀了。他创作了电视剧《超级超市》。而且大家还记得，我们发现他在《悲伤辅导》中为德怀特写了“双胞胎吸收”那句台词。是的。那是简·萨拉塔的深度剖析。我们发现了这一点。好吧，这是贾斯汀的第一部完整剧集。所以我联系了他，因为自从我们杀青后我和贾斯汀一直保持着联系。我必须说，贾斯汀是我最喜欢的人之一。他太可爱了。所以我联系了贾斯汀，问他，这一集的灵感是从哪里来的？以及
he said it was really simple. Greg really wanted to explore this idea of that feeling you get when you have to come back from your vacation and go back to your work grind. And that was it. That was, they built the whole story around that one theme. You know what I love about that is that I find the stories I like the most have such a simple premise. They're not heavy on premise. And I find them usually the most relatable. Same. Same. I feel like that's what made Halloween so great. You have to fire someone on Halloween. Yeah. That's it. That's it. That's it. You've just had a great vacation and now you're faced with the reality of your life back home. Yes. So, then I asked Justin, what was it like being
他说这真的很简单。格雷格非常想探讨这样一种理念：当你结束假期不得不回去面对工作时的那种感受。就是这样。他们围绕这一个主题构建了整个故事。你知道我最喜欢的是什么吗？我发现我最喜欢的那些故事都有着非常简单的切入点。它们的主题并不沉重。而且我发现它们通常最具共鸣感。一样。一样。我觉得这就是万圣节那么棒的原因。你必须在万圣节解雇某人。对。就是这样。就是这样。就是这样。你刚刚度过了一个美妙的假期，现在你不得不面对回家的生活现实。是的。所以，我接着问贾斯汀，作为你的第一个完整剧本，感觉如何？
your first full script? And he said he was incredibly nervous about doing a good job. And he remembers that it was normal for writers to get a full week to write their first draft. You would usually get sent off on a Friday and you would have the whole next week and it wouldn't be due until the following Monday. You'd get about nine days. So, he said that this script, though, they did not finish breaking it until Monday night, pretty late. And Greg said, I'm going to need this Friday morning. So, he only had three days. This is reminding me of when Jean and Lee had to do their first script in like three days. Yeah. Or the time Steve had to write his script over a weekend with his in-laws visiting. Yes, exactly. Exactly.
他说他对于能做好这件事感到非常紧张。他记得当时编剧通常有一整周的时间来写第一稿。你通常会在周五接到任务，然后有一整周的时间，直到下周一才交稿。你大约有九天时间。所以他说，不过这个剧本，他们直到周一晚上才完成剧本大纲，而且已经很晚了。格雷格说，我周五早上就需要它。所以他只有三天时间。这让我想起了简和李曾经不得不在大约三天内完成他们的第一个剧本。是的。或者史蒂夫曾经不得不在岳父母来访的周末写完剧本的那次。是的，没错。没错。
Justin said he grabbed a case of Diet Coke out of the kitchen. He said he basically lived on that for the next 72 hours. Oh, gosh. And I guess apparently after Justin left to go write the script, because you could write your scripts at home, one of the other writers said to Greg, we're not behind. Why does he have to write it so fast? And that Greg smiled and said to keep the pressure up, just tighten in the screws. Oh, Greg. And he said, I think in retrospect, it weirdly did relieve some of the pressure of it being the very first script that he was writing, because no one really expects a script that you write in only three days to be very good. So, he was like, well, this is what it is. He did a dad
贾斯汀说他从厨房拿了一箱健怡可乐。他说他基本上在接下来的72小时里靠这个过活。哦，天哪。我猜显然在贾斯汀离开去写剧本之后，因为你可以在家里写剧本，另一个编剧对格雷格说，我们没有落后啊。为什么他非得写得这么快？格雷格笑着说，为了保持压力，拧紧螺丝。哦，格雷格。他说，回想起来，这奇怪地缓解了作为他写的第一个剧本的一些压力，因为没有人真的指望你只花三天时间写的剧本能有多好。所以他当时想，好吧，事情就是这样。他玩了一个父亲般
mind trick. Oh, my gosh. He was like, yeah, I need it in three days. But also knowing that that way Justin wouldn't like make it too precious and take too long with it and kind of just shake off the cobwebs and jump in the deep end. How many analogies can I use? It was good. I liked them. Well, Justin said he wants everyone to know that what we ended up shooting was way, way better than what he originally wrote, that he brought that script back. And he said he was not able to write the script that you see on the screen in three days. It went through a bunch of rewrites. And basically he said, if I showed you my first draft, your reaction would be, yeah, that pretty much seems like something
心理战。哦，天哪。他当时就像，是的，我三天内就要。但也知道这样贾斯汀就不会把剧本看得太重、花太多时间，而是能甩掉生疏感、直接跳进深水区。我能用多少比喻？这很好。我喜欢它们。好吧，贾斯汀说他想让每个人都知道，我们最后拍摄的内容比他最初写的要好得多、好得多，他把那个剧本拿了回来。他说他根本无法在三天内写出你在屏幕上看到的那个剧本。它经历了多次重写。基本上他说，如果我把我的第一稿拿给你看，你的反应会是，好吧，这看起来确实像一个人花三天时间写出来的东西。
it would take a person three days to write. But anyway, I thought that was so sweet. I love all of that. That's some really great behind the scenes in the writer's room. All right, fastback number two, Angela, directed by Julian Farino. Julian. Julian was born and raised in London. He attended Cambridge University. We loved him. We loved this British man. Well, Jenna, we were so excited to meet him because he had directed an episode of Rome on HBO. And you and I, at this time, were binging that show together. We were really into it. Jenna, I even remember one day when he was on set that we quoted a line to him. We were like, do you remember the line where we were like, 13, 13. Oh, yeah. That was such
不管怎样，我觉得这太美好了。我喜欢所有这些。这些是编剧室里非常棒的幕后故事。好的，第二条花絮，安吉拉，由朱利安·法里诺导演。朱利安。朱利安在伦敦出生长大。他毕业于剑桥大学。我们很喜欢他。我们喜欢这个英国男人。好吧，詹娜，我们非常兴奋能见到他，因为他曾执导过HBO的《罗马》中的一集。而你和我，当时正在一起疯狂追这部剧。我们真的非常迷恋它。詹娜，我甚至还记得有一天他在片场时，我们对他背了一句台词。我们当时说，你还记得那句台词吗，我们说，13，13。哦，是的。那是多么精彩的
a good scene. And he looked at us and he was like, okay, okay, ladies, well, if, if you could go back to reception. Anyway, you guys, Rome was a show on HBO. And in my opinion, Rome was the first Game of Thrones. It was a very Game of Thrones. Yes, it's extremely violent and bloody. And there's lots of warring political factions. What are you wearing? I'm wearing my Game of Thrones shirt because, because I don't know, Rome makes me think of Game of Thrones. So today on the podcast, I'm wearing my Game of Thrones shirt. Well, Julian also directed the first three seasons of Entourage, including Rainn Wilson's episode. I love you too. I just think it's very funny because Charles McDougal, our
一个场景。他看着我们，然后说，好吧，好吧，女士们，如果，如果你们能回到前台去。总之，你们知道，《罗马》是HBO的一部剧。在我看来，《罗马》就是第一部《权力的游戏》。它非常像《权力的游戏》。是的，它极其暴力血腥。并且有很多交战的政治派系。你穿的是什么？我穿着我的《权力的游戏》衬衫，因为，因为我不知道，看到《罗马》就让我想起《权力的游戏》。所以今天在播客里，我穿着我的《权力的游戏》衬衫。好吧，朱利安还执导了《明星伙伴》的前三季，包括雷恩·威尔逊的那集。我也爱你。我只是觉得这非常搞笑，因为查尔斯·麦克道格尔，我们的
other director, had also directed episodes of Rome. I just think it's really funny that we had these guys who had been directing bloody battles come into our little paper company, but they were so fun. I mean, yeah, the, the scale of production that they had to do with chariots tipping over and people flying through the air and, and then literally it'd be like, hey, can you use the stapler slightly harder next to the copier? Like, like, yes, in like our quote unquote action sequence on Dunder Mifflin versus Rome. Well, I think part of Greg's thinking here was remembering that our show was not just a comedy, that it had dramatic elements and was about real human people. And so by having some of these directors
另一个导演，也曾执导过《罗马》的剧集。我只是觉得这真的很好笑，我们让这些曾执导过血腥战役的家伙来到我们这个小小造纸公司，但他们是如此有趣。我是说，是的，他们必须完成的制作规模包括战车翻倒、人员飞过空中，然后字面上就像是，嘿，你能在复印机旁边稍微用力一点使用订书机吗？就像，是的，就像我们在《办公室》对比《罗马》时所谓的动作戏。好吧，我认为格雷格在这里的一些想法是记住我们的节目不仅仅是一部喜剧，它还有戏剧元素，并且是关于真实的人类的。所以通过邀请一些以拍摄这些戏剧、这些以角色为驱动的故事而闻名的导演，我认为这可能就是他被他们吸引的原因。我在推测，但这感觉很对。我喜欢你的推测。我喜欢它。谢谢。好的，我带大家进入第三条花絮。在这一集中，迈克尔散布了一张他自己和简在牙买加度假的照片。是的。然后仓库里的家伙们把它放大成海报，挂在墙上。嗯哼。没错。好吧。我们收到了很多关于这张照片的信件。是的。我们有一个来自普丽莎·辛格尔、阿曼达·麦克奈特、梅根·基尔、梅雷迪思·沃洛、斯蒂芬妮·卡拉汉以及许多其他人的粉丝问题，他们想知道。詹·迈克尔的照片是怎么制作的？是P图吗？
who are known for doing these dramas, these character driven stories, I think that might have been why he was drawn to them. I'm speculating, but that feels right. I like your speculation. I like it. Thank you. Okay, I am moving us to fastback number three. In this episode, Michael circulates a photo of himself and Jan in Jamaica on their vacation. Yes. And then the guys in the warehouse blow it up into a poster and hang it on the wall. Mm hmm. Right. All right. We got a lot of mail about this picture. Yeah. We have a fan question from Prisha Singhal, Amanda McKnight, Megan Keele, Meredith Warlow, Stephanie Callahan and many others they want to know. Was the Jan Michael photo made? Was it photoshopped?
有些人想问史蒂芬·莫洛拉是不是去了牙买加拍这张照片。他们在那里拍了照片吗？这张照片是怎么制作的？大家对这张照片充满了好奇。我们从来没有预算去纽约或斯克兰顿。所以我怀疑他们没去牙买加。开玩笑的。我知道他们没去。他们确实没去。好吧，我联系了肯·萨博纳克（肯百科），还有菲尔·蔡道具公司，他们解释了我们是如何制作这张照片和海报的。准备好了吗？是的。肯告诉我，他们在仓库里搭建了一个微型海滩，一个看起来像海滩的小布景。它有沙子和躺椅，前面是绿幕。我记得那个。我记得我们所有人都看到它，然后就像是
Some people want to know if Steven Malora went to Jamaica to take this picture. Did they do a photo shoot there? How was this picture made? A lot of curiosity about this picture. We never had the budget to all go to New York or Scranton. So I doubt they went to Jamaica. Just kidding. I know they didn't. They did not. Well, I reached out to Kent Sabornak, Kentopedia and also to Filchay Props and they explained how we made this photo and poster. Are you ready? Yes. Kent told me that they built a tiny beach down in the warehouse, a little like set that looked like a beach. It had sand and lounge chairs and it was against a green screen. I remember that. I remember us all seeing it and being like
走到那边去。我完全记得走进仓库，那里有这么一个小海滩。然后他说他和菲尔·蔡联系了桑德斯度假村的人，他们捐赠了各种产品，他们把这些产品展示在里面，比如雨伞和所有写着桑德斯标志的东西。他们把所有这些都放进去了。然后莫洛拉和史蒂夫上了那个小海滩布景，拍了一堆照片，贾斯汀和肯都记得，你知道的，莫洛拉为了这个不需要脱衣服。你们知道的，他们是在Photoshop里处理的。菲尔告诉我，后来他让卡尔弗城的微型图形店把海报打印出来了。这就是他们制作照片的过程。那真是不错的花絮
walking over there. I have a total memory of going down into the warehouse and there was this tiny beach. And then he said that he and Filchay reached out to the people at Sandals Resort who donated all kinds of product, which they featured, like the umbrellas and all of the stuff that said sandals. They put it all in there. So then Malora and Steve got on the little beach set and they took a bunch of pictures and both Justin and Kent remember that, you know, Malora did not have to get nudy for this. They did that in Photoshop, you guys. And Phil told me that then he had the posters printed from a little graphics shop in Culver City. And that is how they made the picture. That was some good fast
女士。嘿，谢谢。好吧，我们休息一下怎么样，詹娜？当我们回来时，我们将从度假中归来。我喜欢。好的。所以我们回来了，让我们切入这一集。有一个非常有趣的冷场开场。是吉姆。他把销售团队叫进会议室，因为迈克尔不在时他负责管理，他正在主持这种销售会议。当然，德怀特肯定会跟吉姆和他的权威针锋相对。所以他在桌子中央放了一个小型录音机来记录会议。然后吉姆当然得捉弄他。他必须捉弄他。他开始说，德怀特，你的裤子怎么脱了？然后德怀特说，我的
facts, lady. Hey, well, thanks. All right. Why don't we take a break, Jenna? And when we come back, we'll be back from vacation. I like it. All right. So we are back and let's get into this episode. There's a really fun cold open. It's Jim. He's got the sales team in the conference room because he's in charge while Michael's away and he's running this sort of sales meeting. Dwight, of course, I'm sure is bumping up against Jim and his authority. So he sets a little recorder in the middle of the table to record the meeting. And then Jim, of course, has to mess with him. He has to mess with him. He starts being like, Dwight, why are your pants off? And he's like, my
裤子没脱。然后大家开始七嘴八舌地插话。然后当然，安迪把它带到了一个荒谬的境地，成了扫兴的人。是的。我们收到了一个关于这个冷场开场的粉丝问题，来自萨姆·特拉扎兹和伊娃·马尔斯。这个冷场开场有多少是即兴发挥的？安吉，我查了剧本，基本上全是按剧本演的。就像吉姆说德怀特在做的事以及凯伦的台词之类的一切都是按剧本来的。我本来以为是即兴的。我觉得这是我们的编剧们发挥得最好的时候。他们太擅长放大喜剧时刻了。所以这符合我的预期。我确实记下了吉姆指控德怀特做的所有事情。你想
pants aren't off. And then everyone starts chiming in. And then of course, Andy takes it to an absurd place and is the fun stopper. Yeah. We had a fan question about this cold open from Sam Terazaz and Eva Mars. How much of the cold open was improvised? And, Ange, I went to the script and it's basically all scripted. Like all of the stuff that Jim says that Dwight is doing and Karen's line and all of that all scripted. I would have thought it was scripted. I feel like this is our writers at their best. Like they were so great at heightening a comedic moment. So that tracks for me. I did write down everything that Jim accused Dwight of doing. Do you want to
听吗？当然。好的。首先，他说，德怀特，你不被允许在办公室中间脱掉裤子。然后他说，哦天哪，他有把刀。他是光着身子的，而且他还拿了一把塑料刀架在斯坦利的脖子上。对不起。对不起。他怎么了？他光着身子？就像他撑起脑袋的脖子是光着的，还是他整个人光着身子？这就像是一整件事。我丈夫总是说，再说一遍。光着（naked，发音成nak-id），光着，光着。
hear? Of course. Okay. So first of all, he says, Dwight, you're not allowed to take off your pants in the middle of the office. And then he's like, oh God, he's got a knife. He's naked and he has the plastic knife to Stanley's neck. I'm sorry. I'm sorry. He's what? He's naked? Like his neck holding up his head is naked or he's naked. This is like a whole thing. My husband's always like, say that again. Naked, naked, naked.
你是怎么发音的？Naked。有个A。它的拼写是N-A-K-E-D。Naked。我老家那是发Naked的音。公平地说，我老家那也是发Naked的音。真的吗？在圣路易斯是发Naked？嗯，在密苏里。哦。就像这很有趣。圣路易斯和密苏里有两种截然不同的口音。如果你来自
How do you say it? Naked. It's an A. It's spelled N-A-K-E-D. Naked. Where I'm from is naked. To be fair, it is also naked where I'm from as well. Really? In St. Louis it's naked? Well in Missouri. Oh. Like it's interesting. St. Louis and Missouri have two kind of different accents. If you're
圣路易斯，你来自密苏里，但如果你来自圣路易斯以外的地方，你来自密苏里，而且你是naked（发音不同）。但如果你来自圣路易斯，你吃饭用叉子。是的。菲利丝总是这么说。她会说，哦，我找不到我的叉子了。没错。所以她在密苏里吃晚饭时会光着身子用叉子吃。但其他人会在密苏里光着身子用叉子吃。好吧，詹娜，如果你在德克萨斯州北部，可别光着身子到处跑。然后他还说德怀特戴着婴儿帽。然后菲利丝太可爱了。她在这个
from St. Louis, you're from Missouri, but if you're from outside of St. Louis, you're from Missouri and you're naked. But if you're from St. Louis, you eat with a fork. Yes. That's what Phyllis would always say. She'd be like, oh, I can't find my fork. Right. So she would eat her dinner naked with a fork in Missouri. But someone else is going to eat it with a fork naked in Missouri. Well, Jenna, if you're in North Texas, don't run around naked. And then he also says that Dwight has a baby's bonnet. And then Phyllis is so adorable. She's so adorable in this
整集中太可爱了。她急切地想插话，她说，吉姆·凯瑞在这里。要个他的签名。你会想，什么？然后凯伦说，你肚子上那个是布偶娃娃的纹身吗？然后，当然，安迪把事情推进到了我要用电锯砍掉菲利丝的头的地步。所有这些里面我最喜欢的部分是，当吉姆说，哦天哪，德怀特正拿着一把塑料刀架在斯坦利的脖子上。镜头切到斯坦利，他甚至连头都没抬。对于房间里发生的一切，他完全没有任何反应。这太棒了。
whole episode. She wants to desperately chime in and she's like, Jim Carrey's here. Get his autograph. You're like, what? And then Karen says, is that a Muppet Baby's Tattoo on your belly? And then, of course, Andy takes it to the place of, I'm chopping off Phyllis's head with a chainsaw. My favorite part of all of that is that when Jim says, oh my God, Dwight is holding a plastic knife to Stanley's neck. The camera pans to Stanley and he does not even look up. He gives absolutely no reaction to everything that's happening in the room. It's awesome.
这太惊人了。太惊人了。我要指出，这个会议室场景是一个会议室桌子场景。注意，桌子在房间里。我们继续吧。抱歉，我因为我怎么发Naked这个音而扯远了。现在迈克尔从牙买加回来了。他超级兴奋。他非常渴望帕姆问他假期过得怎么样。但相反，帕姆告诉他汉娜在他不在的时候辞职了，她还提出了一些投诉，他可能得去作证。迈克尔说，哦，帕姆，这可以等会儿。而她说，这挺重要的。
That's amazing. It's amazing. I will point out that this conference room scene is a conference room table scene. Noted, the table is in the room. Let's move on. Sorry, I took us on a detour with how I say Nicked. So now Michael has returned from Jamaica. He's super excited. He's desperate for Pam to ask him how his vacation was. But instead, Pam lets him know that Hannah quit while he was gone and she's filed some complaints and he might have to be deposed. And Michael's like, oh, Pam, it can wait. And she's like, it's kind of important.
他的确切回答是废话、废话、废话。放松点。有一个非常甜蜜的被删掉的谈话头，是帕姆的谈话头，我觉得它本应该出现在这里的。而且詹娜，你猜怎么着？她说迈克尔从他去的每一个假期都会给她寄一张明信片。我记得拍摄这个谈话头的情景。他们给了我一堆明信片，我一张接一张地把它们举起来，我觉得这很甜蜜，因为这意味着帕姆把它们都攒着。我知道。对我来说，这就好像，你真的看到了帕姆对迈克尔来说是谁。你明白了为什么最终在她（你知道的）在办公室的时光结束时，她是最后一个跟他说话的人。
His exact response was blah, blah, blah. Relax. There's a really sweet deleted talking head that is a Pam talking head that I think would have come about right here. And Jenna, guess what? She says that Michael sends her a postcard from every vacation he takes. I remember shooting this talking head. They gave me a bunch of postcards and I held them up one after the other, which I found sweet because that means Pam saves them. I know. And to me, it's like, you just really see who Pam is to Michael. You see why ultimately she's the last person he speaks to before he leaves at the end of, you know, his time
就像他把她当成家人一样。我真的觉得他是这么想的。好吧，我们为这个开场场景准备了一个粉丝问题。有这样一个时刻，迈克尔向帕姆甩了甩他的头发，因为他在度假时头发上弄了一些小珠子。我跟你说，桑德斯度假村对迈克尔来说就像一个成人夏令营。我是说，他说你是怎么打招呼的，嘿，老兄，然后每个人都大喊，嘿，老兄，我能看出他有多热情。他什么都做，编辫子，学舞蹈，学呐喊。他完全投入了，詹娜。他完全投入了。你说的对。好吧，我们有来自阿什利·布朗宁、霍普·科格比尔的问题。下一个问题是……
on the office. Like he sees her as family. I really think he does. Well, we had a fan question for this opening scene. There's that moment where Michael shakes his hair at Pam because he's gotten some little beads in his hair on his vacation. I'm telling you, Sandals was like a adult camp for Michael. I mean, he says how you go, hey, man, and then everyone yells, hey, man, I can see him being so enthusiastic. He's going to do everything, braid my hair, learn the dances, learn the chance. He's in it, Jenna. He's in it. You're right. Well, we had this question from Ashley Browning, Hope Cogbill,
下一个问题是……
Chris Graham, Rachel LaPointe, and Teresa Rambucuela. They want to know whose idea was it to put the beads in the hair? Were they sewn in? Were they glued in? Well, Jenna, you know, we wanted to get the behind the scenes story on this braid. So we reached out to Kim Ferry, who did our hair on the office for All the Scoop. And this is what she had to say. Well, hello, lovely office ladies. Gosh darn it, I miss both of you so much. Thank you for asking me these questions. As usual, if there were any hair gags, Greg Daniels would either have me paged up or he would come find me. And we would discuss what the look would
克里斯·格雷厄姆、雷切尔·拉潘特和特蕾萨·拉姆库埃拉。他们想知道把珠子编进头发是谁的主意？它们是缝进去的吗？还是粘进去的？好吧，珍娜，你知道的，我们想了解这个辫子背后的故事。所以我们联系了金·费里，她在《办公室》里负责我们的发型。这是她想说的话。哦，你好，可爱的办公室女士们。天哪，我太想念你们两个了。谢谢你们问我这些问题。像往常一样，如果有任何发型恶作剧，格雷格·丹尼尔斯要么会让人传呼我，要么他会来找我。我们会讨论这个造型会是什么样的
be for whatever the actors were doing in this episode. In this one, it was specifically Michael Scott. And I know on the makeup side, he was going to be tan because they wanted him to kind of have that, you know, tan glow from Jamaica. But on my side, it was about having something in his hair. Could it be dreaded? Could it be beaded? You know, what could we do? And in the end, I kind of liked the idea of putting beads in. But I was a little nervous because his hair was only one inch on the sides in the back. He had a short haircut at that time. So I wasn't sure if something would stick in there. But I, you know, I rose to the challenge and told my team I was going to be in the trailer for
演员们在这集里在做什么。在这一集中，具体是迈克尔·斯科特。我知道在妆容方面，他会晒黑，因为他们希望他有一种来自牙买加的古铜色光泽。但在我这边，关键在于他的头发里加点什么。会是脏辫吗？会是串珠吗？你知道，我们能做什么呢？最后，我挺喜欢加珠子的主意。但我有点紧张，因为他的头发两侧和后脑勺只有一英寸长。他当时留着短发。所以我不确定是否有什么东西能固定在上面。但我，你知道的，我迎接了挑战，并告诉我的团队我要在化妆车里呆
a little bit. And I did a couple of variations of it. And I also had human hair. So you can have these actual real human hair clips. And I would sew them into the little things called to pay clips. And I ended up braiding it down probably about two inches long, two to three inches long. And at the very end, I had a little elastic on the bottom. And that really held all the beads in place. And I know I had done a few options for Greg with different colors. But in the end, he liked the red and yellow and green. So that's what we went with. And the little clip, it just kind of like hooks into the hair. So it sticks really well. And if I just back combed it a little bit, and then we did a little bit of hair
一会儿。我做了几个变体。我还有真人头发。所以你可以拥有这些实际的真人发夹。我会把它们缝进一种叫做假发夹的小东西里。最后我把头发编了大约两英寸长，两到三英寸长。在最底部，我有一个小橡皮筋。这真的把所有的珠子都固定在原地了。我知道我为格雷格提供了几种不同颜色的选择。但最后，他喜欢红、黄、绿。所以这就是我们的选择。那个小夹子，它就像是挂在头发上一样。所以它粘得很好。如果我把它稍微倒梳一下，然后我们喷一点发
spray, then pop that clip in, it wasn't going anywhere. And it didn't, it didn't move at all during that episode. So I was very happy. But that's just one of the things that I love doing when I get challenges from Craig, it was always fun to not only make him happy after he saw it, but just to kind of really, he just, he wouldn't do it. It made me so happy when he would smile and he'd be like, yeah, yeah, that's it. So that is my story for this episode. And I miss you both so much. And I'm sending you hugs. And I'm so proud of you. I love your podcast. And I can't wait to hopefully join you guys there someday. All right, you guys take care. Love you both. Bye.
胶，再把那个夹子卡上去，它就哪儿也不去了。而且它在那一集里真的，真的没有动过。所以我很高兴。但这只是我从格雷格那里接到挑战时喜欢做的事情之一，不仅在看到它后让他高兴很有趣，而且还能真正地，他就是，他不会这么做。当他微笑着说，‘对，对，就是这样’时，我真的太开心了。这就是我这一集的故事。我太想念你们两个了。我给你们一个大大的拥抱。我为你们感到骄傲。我爱你们的播客。我等不及希望有一天能加入你们。好了，你们保重。爱你们两个。再见。
Aw, that was so sweet. I love that. I love knowing that they didn't do anything to his actual hair. She would just clip that in and out every day. Yeah, I remember Kim always having these heads with like different like forms of hair and wigs and braids and like whatever she was tinkering on, she had like a row of like fake hair with like different versions of things, especially for Meredith. Oh my gosh. Meredith was always having something done to her hair. So yeah, thank you so much, Kim, for the behind the scenes on that one. So listen, Aunt, I know we're still talking about this opening scene, but I had to bring up something else. What? So when Michael walks through the door,
啊，太甜了。我太喜欢了。我很高兴知道他们没有对他的真发做什么。她每天只是把那个夹子夹上摘下。是的，我记得金总是拿着这些假人头，上面有各种不同形态的头发、假发、辫子，不管她在琢磨什么，她都有一排假头发，上面有各种不同版本的造型，尤其是为了梅丽丝。哦天哪。梅丽丝的发型总是状况不断。所以，是的，非常感谢金为我们带来幕后故事。所以听着，安特，我知道我们还在谈论这个开场镜头，但我得提起另一件事。什么？所以当迈克尔走进门时，
he's carrying like nine gazillion bags, right? And we're going to come to learn that one of them contains this steel drum that he has obsessed with playing. He's holding a box. He's holding bags and a box. And the steel drum, I think, is in the box because it's a big rectangle. Same. But it made me wonder, what is in all the other bags? And that is an amazing deleted scene. Yes, Jenna. So those bags were gifts. They were like souvenirs that he bought everyone. They definitely look like the souvenirs you bought at the airport. And it's all in the deleted scenes. He goes around the office handing them out. Well, I remember doing that scene because the thing he gives Pam is a coconut bra and
他拿着大约九千万个袋子，对吧？然后我们会了解到其中一个袋子里装着这个钢鼓，他沉迷于演奏它。他拿着一个盒子。他拿着袋子和一个盒子。钢鼓，我想，在盒子里，因为它是一个大长方体。我也是。但这也让我好奇，其他所有袋子里装的是什么？那是一个了不起的被删场景。是的，珍娜。所以那些袋子是礼物。它们就像他买给每个人的纪念品。它们看起来绝对像你在机场买的纪念品。这全在被删场景里。他在办公室里四处分发。嗯，我记得拍那场戏，因为他给帕姆的东西是一个椰子胸罩，然后
he's like some coconuts for your coconuts. And I'm like, thanks. Diddy says, do you want to see if it fits? And you're like, no. I'm not going to go try on this coconut bikini top right now. Thanks. Yes, exactly. But I remember shooting that with Steve because I couldn't get through it. Every time I opened it up, it was so ludicrous to me that that was the gift he gave Pam. It would make me laugh. He gives Angela Martin a lay and he puts it around her neck. And she's like, thank you. And he goes, you just got laid. And I'm like, no, I didn't. And you like rip it off, right? Yeah, I get really mad. Well, next we're going to find out that Karen and Jim are experiencing some tension.
他说，‘给你的一些椰子准备的椰子。’我说，‘谢谢。’迪迪说，‘你想看看它合身吗？’你说，‘不。’我才不去试穿这个椰子比基尼上衣呢。谢谢。是的， exatamente。但我记得和史蒂夫一起拍那场戏，因为我演不下去。每次我打开它，我都觉得那是他送给帕姆的礼物，实在是太荒谬了。这会逗笑我。他给安吉拉·马丁送了一条花环，并把它挂在她的脖子上。她说，‘谢谢你。’他说，‘你刚被搞（lay）了。’我说，‘不，我没有。’然后你就像把它扯下来，对吧？是的，我真的很生气。好吧，接下来我们会发现卡伦和吉姆之间有些紧张。
Oh, yeah. And here is why. It is because Jim does not want Karen to move into an apartment that is two blocks away from his apartment, even though she's been having a really hard time finding an apartment and she is currently living in a motel. She's at a day's end. That's what we learned that in a deleted scene. I mean, come on. Well, she says it down in the warehouse to Pam as well later. She needs to find a place to live. You know what I noticed? When Karen does her talking head, she's standing at the copier in the annex. Remember in the other episode, we were like, is this copier always here? That's where she's standing. That's backed by Kelly's desk and Toby's desk in the annex. Jenna, what does it mean if your
哦，是的。原因如下。那是因为吉姆不想让卡伦搬进离他公寓只有两个街区远的一家公寓，尽管她一直在找公寓，而且现在住在一个汽车旅馆里。她住在戴斯酒店。这就是我们在一个被删场景中了解到的。我是说，拜托。好吧，她后来也在仓库里对帕姆说了。她需要找个地方住。你们知道我注意到什么了吗？当卡伦做她的单人访谈（talking head）时，她站在附属建筑（annex）的复印机旁。还记得在上一集里，我们还在讨论说，这台复印机一直都在这儿吗？她就站在那儿。后面靠着凯莉的桌子和托比在附属建筑的桌子。珍娜，如果你的
talking head is in the annex? What does that mean? What does it mean? I think it means you're trying to avoid somebody and you're using the copier in the annex. Yeah. Jenna, speaking of deleted scenes, there's another great runner between Phyllis and Stanley because you know, Stanley says he doesn't get all of his bonus and he's not going to work, not a lick until he gets that bonus money. And it starts driving Phyllis crazy because he won't answer his phone. She has a phenomenal talking head. So that's in the DVD deleted scenes. I remember shooting those and they were very funny. And I love anytime there's a dynamic between Phyllis and Stanley. So now we're in Michael's office and he's playing the steel drum for Pam. He's telling her all about
单人访谈在附属建筑拍，这意味着什么？那意味着什么？这意味着什么？我想这意味着你在试图躲避某人，而你在使用附属建筑里的复印机。是的。珍娜，说到被删场景，菲利斯和斯坦利之间还有另一个精彩的情节，因为你知道的，斯坦利说他没有拿到全额奖金，在拿到奖金之前他绝不工作，连一下都不干。这把菲利斯快逼疯了，因为他不接电话。她有一个极其精彩的单人访谈。所以那是在DVD的被删场景中。我记得拍过那些，它们非常有趣。而且我喜欢菲利斯和斯坦利之间的任何化学反应。所以现在我们在迈克尔的办公室，他正在为帕姆演奏钢鼓。他一直在向她滔滔不绝地讲述
his trip to Jamaica. He's explaining that everyone in Jamaica just relaxes all day and they party all the time. They love it. Yeah. He's like, write this down, Pam. Pina Coladas every day at 3 p.m. Like he is just, he is definitely not ready to go back to work. And this is when Pam breaks the news to him that they have to do inventory, which is something that he was hoping to avoid by going on vacation. And she says, Michael, we can't do inventory without you. We had to wait. It has to be done today. He is so bummed out. He hates doing inventory. He says it's boring. So he decides to make it a party. And he tells Angela, get the party planning committee together. We're going to have a luau this afternoon. And she is not having it.
他去牙加的旅行。他解释说牙买加的每个人整天都在放松，他们一直在派对。他们太喜欢了。是的。他就像是，‘把它记下来，帕姆。每天下午3点喝Piña Coladas。’就像他绝对没有准备好回去工作。就在这时，帕姆向他抛出一个重磅炸弹，告诉他们必须做盘点，这是他一直希望通过度假来躲避的事情。她说，‘迈克尔，没有你我们做不了盘点。我们得等。今天必须完成。’他太沮丧了。他讨厌做盘点。他说这太无聊了。所以他决定把它变成一个派对。他告诉安吉拉，把派对策划委员会叫来。我们今天下午要办一个夏威夷传统烤猪宴（luau）。而她根本不买账。
She's like, what? At four minutes, you get a shot of a real snarky expression from Angela Martin about this luau that she now has to throw. But please look at the outfit. Crazy blouse with a high collar, frufy collar, Argyle sweater in shades of beige and brown, brown skirt, ponytail with what Kim Ferry and I called the sloop. This is a classic Angela Martin outfit. If I have to say so myself. Well, lady, we had a fan question from Katie Wegman, who is asking, is the shirt that you're wearing the same one you wore in Benihana Christmas because it looks almost identical? No, it is not. This season, the wardrobe department had bought me all of these high-collared, frufy blouses, which only lived this season and never come back. But that is not
她说，‘什么？’在第四分钟，你可以看到安吉拉·马丁对这个她现在不得不举办的烤猪宴露出了一个非常讽刺的表情。但请看看这套衣服。疯狂的衬衫，高领，褶边领，米色和棕色色调的菱形格毛衣，棕色裙子，马尾辫，我和金·费里称之为“下垂头”的发型。这是一个经典的安吉拉·马丁造型。如果我这么说的话。好吧，女士们，我们有一个来自凯蒂·韦格曼的粉丝提问，她问，你身上穿的那件衬衫和你在《班妮汉娜圣诞节》里穿的是同一件吗，因为它们看起来几乎一模一样？不，不是的。这个季度，服装部门给我买了很多这种高领、有褶边的衬衫，它们只在这个季度出现，再也没有回来过。但那不是
the same one. It's yet another frufy blouse. Well, now we go into the conference room, Angela, because Michael wants everyone to watch a video slideshow on island life. And a big thing happened. Karen does not sit next to Jim. Yeah. It's serious. This fight is serious. And then while they're watching this slideshow, Pam spots Jan on the beach with Michael. But he denies that it's her. Jenna, hold up. I have written down here. Pam pulls a Michael. Pam, why did you call it out? Why? I mean, that's something Michael would do. I feel like a normal move for Pam would be to notice Jan. Totally know it was her and not say anything. And instead be like, oh, right? And then maybe go be chatty with Jim about it later. But instead, Pam points at the screen and goes,
同一件。这又是一件有褶边的衬衫。好吧，现在我们走进会议室了，安吉拉，因为迈克尔想让大家看一段关于岛屿生活的视频幻灯片。而且发生了一件大事。卡伦没有坐在吉姆旁边。是的。事情很严重。这场争端很严重。然后当他们看幻灯片时，帕姆发现詹和迈克尔在沙滩上。但他否认那是她。珍娜，等等。我这里写着：帕姆来了个“迈克尔”。帕姆，你为什么要喊出来？为什么？我是说，那是迈克尔会做的事。我觉得帕姆正常的举动应该是注意到詹。完全知道那是她，然后什么也不说。相反，她会说，‘哦，真的吗？’然后可能稍后会和吉姆闲聊这事。但相反，帕姆指着屏幕说，
wait, is that Jan? That's Jan. And I feel like that's something Michael or Dwight would have done normally. I totally hear that. I think that's a valid analysis. I will say, I think it was probably so shocking to Pam that she just blurted it out. I mean, it's to see Jan in the picture. She just, I imagined she was just like, oh my gosh. Okay, okay, fair enough. Okay, I get it. Well, we had a fan question about this scene, Angela, from Marin Allen. She wrote in to say, my 13-year-old daughter Dakota pointed out that when Pam notices Jan and Michael's vacation slideshow, Michael says that she's actually a German woman named Ergelgrew. And my daughter would like to know if this name was improvised and if it has anything to do with Steve's despicable
‘等一下，那是詹吗？那是詹。’我觉得这通常是迈克尔或德怀特会做的事。我完全理解。我认为这是一个合理的分析。我要说的是，我想这对帕姆来说可能太震惊了，以至于她脱口而出了。我是说，在照片里看到詹。她只是，我想象她当时一定觉得，‘哦，天哪。’好吧，好吧，有道理。好吧，我懂了。好吧，关于这一场戏，安吉拉，我们有一个来自玛丽恩·阿伦的粉丝提问。她写信说，她13岁的女儿达科塔指出，当帕姆注意到詹和迈克尔的度假幻灯片时，迈克尔说她其实是一个名叫Ergelgrew的德国女人，她的女儿想知道这个名字是不是即兴发挥的，这跟史蒂夫招人喜欢的
me character grew. I had the same question. So I looked it up. This episode was filmed in 2007, back from vacation. Despicable Me came out in 2010. So then I researched animation production and how long it takes a movie like Despicable Me to be made. And they take three to five years. So it is possible that there was an overlap that Steve was doing voiceover while we were filming on the office. It's possible. Oh my gosh. And maybe that is why, because in the script, it says Ergelgrew, but he says Ergelgrew, maybe it was like on his mind. And that's why he said grew. Let's move it on. Michael, I mean, he's got to tell someone, right? He's so excited to tell Packer that Jan went with him to Jamaica. And Packer doesn't believe him. He's like, no way.
《卑鄙的我》里的格鲁角色有什么关系吗？我也有同样的疑问。所以我查了一下。这一集是2007年拍摄的，度假回来。《卑鄙的我》是2010年上映的。然后我研究了动画制作以及像《卑鄙的我》这样的电影需要制作多长时间。它们需要三到五年。所以有可能存在重叠，即当我们在《办公室》拍摄时，史蒂夫正在做配音。这是可能的。哦，天哪。也许这就是原因，因为在剧本里，写的是Ergelgrew，但他读作Ergelgrew，也许它一直在他脑子里。这就是为什么他说成了格鲁。我们继续吧。迈克尔，我是说，他得告诉某人，对吧？他太兴奋了，想告诉帕克詹跟他一起去了牙买加。而帕克不相信他。他说，‘不可能。’
So Michael's like, you know what, I'll send you a picture. And Packer's email is Packer at Dunder Mifflin. But he sends it to Packaging at Dunder Mifflin. And how this all goes down in the scene is so great. Because Michael is like, did you get it? Hit refresh, hit refresh. And Packer is like, no, I didn't get it. And then all of a sudden he says, oh, I just got it from someone else. And then Michael's like, wait, wait, what? Who else? What? And then Michael realizes he has sent it to the wrong place. He sent it to Daryl in the warehouse, who has clearly forwarded it to Packer or someone else who forwarded it to Packer. But it is out, basically. I want to point out that that line at the end, when Packer says, how do I get you out of this picture? That was an improv.
所以迈克尔说，‘你知道吗，我给你发张照片。’帕克的电子邮件是Packer@DunderMifflin。但他发给了Packaging@DunderMifflin。这场戏的发展太棒了。因为迈克尔说，‘你收到了吗？按刷新，按刷新。’而帕克说，‘不，我没收到。’然后突然他说，‘哦，我刚从别人那儿收到了。’然后迈克尔说，‘等等，等等，什么？还有谁？什么？’然后迈克尔意识到他发错地方了。他发给了仓库里的达里尔，达里尔显然把它转发给了帕克或转发给帕克的某个人。但无论如何，事情败露了。我想指出，最后那句台词，当帕克说，“我怎么才能让你从这张照片里消失？”那是即兴创作。
That was a Dave Keckner ad. Yeah, that's that's Dave Keckner at his best. After Michael gets off the phone with Packer, he is freaked out. Oh, he's freaking the heck out. He needs to do damage control. So he runs, he sprints to the warehouse. We had a fan question from Anna Rhodes. She says, at seven minutes, 20 seconds, where is that hallway that Michael is running down to get to the warehouse? Anna, I had the same question. So I did some digging, but Jenna, I know you did too. And you went to Kentopedia. So what do you got? All right, Kent told me that that is the hallway where our writers work. He is running down the writers hallway. All those doors you see are writers offices. And when he turns the corner,
那是大卫·科克纳的自由发挥。是的，那是巅峰时期的戴夫·科克纳。迈克尔和帕克挂了电话后，他吓坏了。哦，他吓得魂飞魄散。他需要进行危机公关。所以他跑着，冲向仓库。我们有一个来自安娜·罗兹的粉丝提问。她说，在7分20秒处，迈克尔跑着去仓库的那条走廊是哪儿？安娜，我也有同样的疑问。所以我做了一些挖掘，但我知道你也是，珍娜。你去了肯托百科（Kentopedia）。你有什么发现？好吧，肯告诉我，那是我们编剧工作的走廊。他正沿着编剧走廊奔跑。你看到的那些门都是编剧办公室。当他拐过弯，
and he runs through that doorway, he is running into Mindy Kaling's office. Is he really? Yes. Oh my God, I thought that was Kent's office. Oh my gosh. Okay, I love that. Well, I have a little catch, Jenna. He runs past a woman sitting at a desk, right, right at the very beginning of his sprint. Well, that is Mary Wall. And she was our executive producer assistant. She's in an orange hoodie. She she was the best. She did everything for us. I love that we put Mary in that scene. So I guess they just made all the writers close their doors. But they let Mary keep working. And they just shot that scene. Steve ran right past her. Yeah. And the desk that Mary is sitting at is directly outside of the writers room conference room. They had their own conference
他跑过那个门道，他跑进了敏迪·卡灵的办公室。真的吗？是的。哦，天哪，我还以为那是肯的办公室呢。哦，天哪。好吧，我喜欢这个。好吧，我有一个小发现，珍娜。他跑过一个坐在办公桌前的女人，就在他开始冲刺的刚开始。好吧，那是玛丽·沃尔。她是我们的执行制片人助理。她穿着一件橙色连帽衫。她，她是最好的。她为我们做了一切。我喜欢我们把玛丽安排在那场戏里。所以我想他们只是让所有编剧关上门。但他们让玛丽继续工作。他们就那样拍了那场戏。史蒂夫从她身旁跑过。是的。玛丽坐的桌子直接位于编剧室会议室外面。他们有自己的会议
room. And Steve starts his sprint right in the doorway of that writers room conference room. And he runs right past Mary at the desk outside of it. Well, after he runs into Mindy's office, obviously, it's a dead end. So they had to cut there. Then Steve had to go down into the warehouse, walk up the steps and get into that little fake box at the top of the stairs that actually leads nowhere. And then come back down. Yes. And then they would yell action and he would come running back down the stairs as if he had actually come from somewhere. Right. So then he runs into Daryl's office. And I believe Angela, this is the first time we've seen Daryl's office in the warehouse, where we've actually gone inside of it. In this scene at seven minutes, 38 seconds,
室。史蒂夫就在那个编剧室会议室的门口开始冲刺。他直接跑过坐在外面桌旁的玛丽。好吧，在他跑进敏迪的办公室后，显然，那是条死胡同。所以他们不得不切掉画面。然后史蒂夫不得不走到仓库里，走上台阶，钻进楼梯顶端那个实际上通往任何地方的假箱子里。然后走下来。是的。然后他们会喊开拍，他就会像真的从某处赶来一样，再次从楼梯上跑下来。对。然后他跑进达里尔的办公室。我相信安吉拉，这是我们在仓库里第一次看到达里尔的办公室，我们真的进到里面去了。在这场戏的7分38秒，
Daryl is eating a giant plate of food. We had a fan question from Dave H and Andrea Poteet Bell. What is up with Daryl's massive plate of food? When Michael goes in to ask him about the picture? Well, Angela, it is not in the script that Daryl is eating. And usually, it is. Usually, it is scripted that we're eating food. Here's why I went to look. When I looked at that plate of food, it 100% looked like the stuff they would serve us at craft services. I thought the same thing, Jenna. Oh my God. When I looked at it, I was like, is Craig, as Daryl, just holding his lunch or like a smoky maid? Yeah. I think he was hungry and he was having a plate of food and they were like, oh, you should just eat that in the scene.
达里尔正在吃一大盘食物。我们有一个来自戴夫·H和安德烈·波蒂特·贝尔的粉丝提问。达里尔那一盘巨型食物是怎么回事？当迈克尔进去问他关于照片的事时？好吧，安吉拉，达里尔在吃东西并不在剧本里。通常情况下，是这样的。通常剧本里会写我们在吃东西。这就是为什么我去查了一下。当我看到那一盘食物时，它100%看起来像是他们会在后勤餐饮（craft services）上端给我们的东西。我有同感，珍娜。哦，天哪。当我看到它时，我在想，作为达里尔的克雷格，是只是拿着他的午餐还是像熏肉女仆？是的。我想他当时饿了，他有一盘食物，然后他们说，‘哦，你干脆在戏里吃那个吧。’
That food brought me back. I had a sense memory when I saw the plate. I was like, that's our food. That's what we used to eat all the time. Yeah, especially like they would bring in those big trays of chicken wings, remember? Yes. Like drumsticks and wings. Yes. Well, so when Michael is there, he's asking Daryl, did you get my email? And Daryl's like, yeah. And he's like, well, did you get my email about deleting that email? And Daryl's like, you know what, Mike? I'm very busy down here. So clearly, Daryl is going to be no help in getting Michael's picture deleted. Oh no. Well, I want to take us back to accounting for a second, Jenna, humor me for some background catches. At eight minutes, 12 seconds, Andy, Meredith, and Jim are gathered
那些食物把我带回去了。当我看到那个盘子时，我有一种感官记忆。我想，那是我们的食物。那是我们以前经常吃的东西。是的，尤其是他们会带进来那些大盘的鸡翅，记得吗？是的。像鸡腿和鸡翅。是的。好吧，所以当迈克尔在那儿时，他问达里尔，“你收到我的电子邮件了吗？”达里尔说，“收到了。”他说，“好吧，你收到我关于删除那封电子邮件的电子邮件了吗？”达里尔说，“你知道吗，迈克，我在下面很忙。”很显然，达里尔对帮迈克尔删除照片毫无帮助。哦，不。好吧，我想把我们带回会计部一会儿，珍娜，为了照顾我的一些背景小发现，请迁就我一下。在8分12秒，安迪、梅丽丝和吉姆聚集在
around Kevin's computer looking at the photo. Now over Kevin's shoulder, you can see a message on his bulletin board that says, don't eat the yellow snow. Maybe Kevin, maybe Kevin needed a reminder. But at eight minutes, 18 seconds, there is a post-it note on Angela Martin's side of the partition. And Jenna, I zoomed in on that sucker. I zoomed on it so hard. And do you know what it says? We got so much mail about this post-it note, Angela, you're going to make so many people very happy right now. What does it say? Well, I have to thank my husband, Josh, because this was half an hour of our lives that I made him do with me. He has editing software. I made him screen grab, blow it up. We put different filters on it that would highlight different letters. You guys,
凯文的电脑周围看照片。现在在凯文的肩膀上方，你可以看到他的公告板上有一条消息，上面写着：“不要吃黄色的雪”。也许凯文，也许凯文需要一个提醒。但在8分18秒，在安吉拉·马丁那一侧的隔板上有一张便利贴。珍娜，我把那个小东西放大了。我把它放得超级大。你知道上面写着什么吗？我们收到了关于这张便利贴的大量邮件，安吉拉，你现在会让很多人非常高兴的。上面写着什么？好吧，我得感谢我的丈夫乔什，因为这是我和他一起度过的半小时人生。他有编辑软件。我让他截屏、放大。我们给它加了不同的滤镜，可以突出显示不同的字母。你们，
it was a huge task, but we did it. This is what we, 99.9% believe that it says after our half an hour research. Angela, can I have $8 petty cash to buy some more jelly beans? I'll get you licorice and cherry. Thanks, Pam. Oh my gosh. I'll get you licorice and cherry. Well, you know that Dwight likes licorice. Wow. I guess you're the one who likes cherry. I guess so. But we literally, it was like, it was like we had found the Rosetta Stone. We're like, that's an R. I'm positive. Okay, that's a C. That's a Y. Like literally, like we were like figuring out hieroglyphics and we became obsessed. And that's what we're pretty sure it says. Well, what I love about that is that it reveals that Pam doesn't pay for her own candy. She gets petty cash from Angela and that
这是一项艰巨的任务，但我们做到了。经过我们半小时的研究，这是我们99.9%确信它写的内容。安吉拉，我能有8美元的零用钱买些果冻豆吗？我给你买甘草味和樱桃味的。谢谢，帕姆。哦，天哪。我给你买甘草味和樱桃味的。好吧，你知道德怀特喜欢甘草味。哇。我猜你才是那个喜欢樱桃味的人。我想是的。但我们真的，感觉就像我们找到了罗塞塔石碑。我们说，那是个R。我确信。好吧，那是个C。那是个Y。就像字面意思一样，我们就像在破译象形文字一样，我们着迷了。这就是我们深信不疑的内容。好吧，我喜欢的是，它透露出帕姆不自己买糖果。她从安吉拉那里拿零用钱，而她
it is something that Pam is doing for the office almost like maybe the person before her did it too. I could imagine Pam starting work and Angela going up to her and saying, you will put out candy on your desk. I will give you petty cash. You need to bring me a receipt. But like this is part of Pam's like work list. Yeah, it made me rethink front reception too, especially during the holidays because I thought all those little decorations I always sort of thought that was Pam's effort to spruce up her desk area. But now I think maybe Angela Martin is like, remember, you have a budget for decorating the front reception. It's the first thing people see when they walk through the door. Yeah, like this candy and the decorations are mandated. Can we though believe that Pam buys
这是潘为办公室做的事，就像她之前的那个人可能也做过一样。我可以想象潘开始上班时，安吉拉走到她面前对她说，你得在桌上摆些糖果。我会给你零用钱。你需要拿收据给我。但这就像是潘的工作清单的一部分。是的，这也让我重新审视了前台接待处，特别是在节日期间，因为我以前总是认为那些小装饰是潘为了美化她的办公区而付出的努力。但现在我觉得，可能是安吉拉·马丁在说，记住，你有一笔装饰前台的预算。这是人们进门时看到的第一个东西。是的，就像这些糖果和装饰都是强制规定的。不过我们真的相信潘会自己买
the plants herself? If you want to. Thanks. She can't keep any of them alive. But okay. Okay. All right. So now we have two things happening. We have Michael who tells Dwight about the photo. He says he needs Dwight's help in retrieving it. My favorite part of this scene is when we learned that Michael has named the photo Jamaican Jan Sun Princess. Amazing. And then the other thing that happens is that Jim is sad, sad Jim is in the break room. Pam walks in and she gets Jim to confide in her. And he says that he is in kind of a stupid fight with Karen. And Pam says, do you want to talk about it? I have a question for you. What do you really think that Pam wants to talk about it? Or do you think
这些植物吗？如果你想的话。谢谢。她根本养不活任何植物。但好吧。好吧。好吧。所以现在有两件事发生了。迈克尔把照片的事告诉了德怀特。他说他需要德怀特帮他找回照片。我这一段最喜欢的部分是，我们得知迈克尔给那张照片取名叫“牙买加简太阳公主”。太棒了。然后发生的事是吉姆很难过，难过的吉姆在茶水间里。潘走了进去，她让吉姆向她倾诉。吉姆说他和凯伦吵了一架，挺蠢的架。潘说，你想聊聊吗？我有个问题想问你。你觉得潘是真的想聊聊吗？还是你觉得
somewhere deep in her subconscious, I don't think she's a mean spirited person, but maybe she has found a way just to spend time with him again? Of course. Of course. She has ulterior motives here. Well, I think it's also though. You know what? I actually don't think she has those ulterior motives. I think she is really trying to believe and convince herself that she can have a friendship with Jim and that this is what friends do. So yes, I think part of her is craving that connection. But I think the real thing and why she's going to break down later is that she thinks she's ready to be this kind of friend to him. And she's going to find out that she's not right. She thinks that she is and this is her attempt. Well, I'll tell you,
在她的潜意识深处，我并不认为她是一个刻薄的人，但也许她只是找到了一种能再次和他共度时光的方法？当然。当然。她在这里有不可告人的动机。嗯，不过我也觉得。你知道吗？其实我倒不觉得她有什么不可告人的动机。我觉得她是真的在努力去相信并说服自己，她可以和吉姆做朋友，而这就是朋友该做的事。所以，是的，我觉得她的一部分内心渴望那种连接。但我觉得真正的原因，也是她等会儿要崩溃的原因是，她以为自己已经准备好做他这种类型的朋友了。结果她会发现自己其实并没有准备好，对吧。她以为自己准备好了，而这就是她的尝试。好吧，我告诉你，
there's a deleted scene between Jim and Pam. I'm actually for their storyline. I think it was the right thing to delete it because it takes Pam's sort of earnestness to want to help him and try to really be a good friend to him. And it makes it seem like maybe she just wanted to hang out with him. And it's the two of you at front reception at Pam's computer, kind of in that canoodling form, the way you guys used to play in pranks on Dwight and he'd be leaning in, you'd be laughing and looking at each other. You're doing all of that, but you're looking for apartments together for Karen. Oh, and it felt, it felt off. And so I think it was the right move to delete it. I'm glad they deleted that because my takeaway from this episode was that Pam was being really
吉姆和潘之间有一段被删掉的场景。我其实很支持他们的这条剧情线。我觉得删掉它是正确的决定，因为它削弱了潘想要帮助他、真心想做他好朋友的那种真诚。而且这让人感觉好像她只是想和他一起鬼混。镜头拍的是你们两个在前台潘的电脑旁，那种卿卿我我的姿势，就像你们以前捉弄德怀特时那样，他会身体前倾，你们会大笑并看着彼此。你们在做这一切，但你们却在为凯伦一起找公寓。哦，感觉，感觉不对劲。所以我认为删掉它是明智的做法。我很高兴他们删掉了那段，因为我这一集最大的感悟是潘真的很
earnest. Yeah. And then just realized she can't, she can't be that yet. Well, we also get a big piece of information about Jim and Karen's relationship in the scene. We find out that they've been dating a month. Jim says we've only been dating a month. That is not very long. No. So definitely the whole dating thing started after she moved to Scranton because we are about four weeks into her move. That kind of makes Jim's argument makes sense. I mean, if you just started dating someone, you're only dating them a month, you might not want them living right down the street because you're like, what if it doesn't work out? Yeah, but are you really going to see them that much unless you want to? I mean, it's not like they're direct neighbors or
真诚。是的。然后她突然意识到自己还不行，她还不能那样做。嗯，我们在这一幕里也得到了关于吉姆和凯伦关系的重要信息。我们发现他们已经交往一个月了。吉姆说我们才交往一个月。那时间真的很短。不短。所以毫无疑问，整个交往过程是从她搬到斯克兰顿之后才开始的，因为她搬来大概四周了。这就让吉姆的论点说得通了。我的意思是，如果你刚开始和某人交往，才交往了一个月，你可能不想让他们住在你这条街上，因为你会想，万一事情黄了怎么办？对啊，但除非你想，否则你真的会经常见到他们吗？我的意思是，他们又不是直接的邻居或者
living in the same building. I don't know. Two blocks away is far if you want it to be. I don't know. I might be on Jim's side on this one. I guess I'm Sam. I might be like, hey, I want to be able to go for a walk or jog. I mean, who are we kidding? I'm not jogging anywhere. But like, my point is, I don't know. That might be too close. So in the end, Pam tells Jim that she thinks maybe he's being unreasonable. Maybe he should reconsider. She very gently suggests this. And then they start giggling about the fact that Michael went to Jamaica with Jan. Yes. And that must feel like a little bit like, like they're back. And that must make Pam happy. You know, that's like that moment. I want to give a little shout out to a Toby line because Toby confronts
住在同一栋楼里。我不知道。如果你希望的话，隔两条街也很远。我不知道。在这个问题上我可能站在吉姆这边。我想我是萨姆。我可能会想，嘿，我想去散步或慢跑。我的意思是，我们在开什么玩笑？我才不在哪慢跑呢。但我的意思是，我不知道。那可能太近了。所以最后，潘告诉吉姆，她觉得他可能有点无理取闹了。也许他应该重新考虑一下。她非常温和地提出了这个建议。然后他们开始咯咯地笑起来，因为迈克尔和简一起去了牙买加。是的。那感觉一定有点像，就像他们回到了过去。这一定让潘很高兴。你知道，那就是那种时刻。我想对托比的一句台词表达一点敬意，因为托比在下一幕中质问了
Michael in the next scene, saying that he has to report it if he's having a relationship, you know, with a co-worker. And Michael's denying everything, but Toby says nine different people emailed me that photo, including my ex-wife. And we don't even really talk. I love that. And then that made me laugh out loud. And then Michael's responses, well, maybe this will be the icebreaker. That's how Mike responds to that. But if it just shows you how far and wide this photo is going now. So now here's what's happening in the rest of the office. Angela's in the conference room. She is called together an emergency meeting of the party planning committee.
迈克尔，说如果他和同事谈恋爱，他必须上报，你知道的。迈克尔矢口否认一切，但托比说有九个人把那张照片发邮件给我了，包括我的前妻。我们平时甚至都不怎么说话。我太喜欢这句了。然后这逗得我哈哈大笑。接着迈克尔的回应是，嗯，也许这会是个破冰的好话题。迈克尔就是这样回应的。但这恰恰说明这张照片现在传得有多广，范围有多大。好啦，接下来办公室里发生了什么。安吉拉在会议室里。她召集了派对策划委员会的紧急会议。
How are they going to throw this luau? She's very stressed. Oh, she's not happy about it. So then the very next scene, we're all out in the bullpen again. We're done with our meeting, apparently Pam is back at reception. She's fielding a phone call from Jan. This must be a time jump. Maybe it was a continuity error. I don't know. There's a little, there are a couple of times when Pam is both in the break room talking to Jim and at the reception desk. Pam has superpowers. She's like all over the place. Pam is in a lot of places at once in this episode.
他们要怎么办这场夏威夷草裙舞派对呢？她压力很大。哦，她对此很不高兴。所以紧接着下一幕，我们又回到了大办公室。我们的会议开完了，显然潘回到了前台。她正在接听简打来的电话。这一定是个时间跳跃。也许是个连贯性错误。我不知道。有那么一小会儿，有几次潘既在茶水间跟吉姆说话，又在前台接待处。潘有超能力。她简直无处不在。在这集里，潘同时出现在很多地方。
But in this moment, Jan has called the office and Michael will not take the call. He is freaking out. He says he will call Jan back. And I want to note, Angela, not only are you not in the conference room at 12 minutes, four seconds, you are standing at the mail cart with Andy. Hold up, lady. Three seconds ago, you were shredding green construction paper to make decorations for the luau. Now you're at the mail cart. What's happening? Using the mail cart, apparently very important mail cart tracking. What with Andy?
但在此时，简打来办公室电话，而迈克尔拒接。他快吓疯了。他说他会回电话给简。我要指出的是，安吉拉，在12分04秒时，你不仅不在会议室里，你还和安迪一起站在邮箱推车旁。等等，这位女士。三秒钟前，你还在碎绿色的建筑纸来给草裙舞派对做装饰。现在你在邮箱推车旁了。怎么回事？在用邮箱推车，显然是非常重要的邮箱推车追踪。还和安迪一起？
Well, I have a question for you, Jenna. At 12 minutes, 14 seconds, Dwight opens Michael's office window, not the window that faces the bullpen, the window that faces like front reception in the couch, you know, the hallway as you come in, he slides the window open and tries to poke his head through the blinds to tell Michael he needs to come down to the warehouse ASAP. Yeah. Jenna, is that the first and only time that window is open? I'm not sure. I feel like we've opened that window before and there were other people who wrote in and pointed that out that why did Dwight do that? How did he do that? But yeah, he slid the window open and spoke through the blinds, I guess because
嗯，我有个问题要问你，珍娜。在12分14秒时，德怀特打开了迈克尔办公室的窗户，不是朝向大办公区的窗户，而是朝向前台沙发的那扇窗户，你知道的，就是你进来时的那个走廊，他把窗户推开，试图透过百叶窗把头探进去，告诉迈克尔他需要马上到仓库去。是的。珍娜，那是那扇窗户第一次也是唯一一次被打开吗？我不确定。我觉得我们以前好像也开过那窗户，而且还有其他人写信指出过这一点，问为什么德怀特要那样做？他是怎么做到的？但确实，他把窗户推开，隔着百叶窗说话，我猜是因为
he's been in the warehouse, he's run upstairs and he needs to tell Michael immediately. And for some reason, I guess he thinks this is more secretive or something away to get Michael's attention. I mean, it was so jarring to me. I'm like, oh, God, Dwight, where are you coming from? What's happening? Well, then Michael and Dwight, they do that run down the hallway again. They go into the warehouse to discover that they have turned his picture with Jan into a giant poster and hung it on the wall and all the guys start applauding for Michael. Michael is so conflicted in this moment. He doesn't know if he wants to be popular or if he wants to do the right thing. Yeah. And you know, Jan is legendary within this office. She is the corporate boss. So this is a
他一直在仓库里，他跑上楼来，需要立刻告诉迈克尔。出于某种原因，我猜他觉得这样更隐蔽，或者这是吸引迈克尔注意的某种方式。我的意思是，这让我太震惊了。我想，哦，天哪，德怀特，你从哪儿来？发生什么事了？好吧，然后迈克尔和德怀特又顺着走廊跑了下去。他们走进仓库，发现大家把他和简的照片做成了一张巨型海报挂在墙上，所有小伙子们都开始为迈克尔鼓掌。此时的迈克尔内心十分纠结。他不知道自己是想当个受欢迎的人，还是想做正确的事。是的。而且你知道的，简在办公室里是个传奇人物。她是公司的老板。所以这是一个
big story. And yeah, Michael is very conflicted. All right. Well, I think maybe we should take a break. And when we come back, we'll figure out how Michael is going to solve this problem and see if this luau party actually happens. Yes. All right, we are back. Michael makes an announcement in the office and tells everyone that they have to delete this photo that is not Jan. It could be Jan, but it's not Jan. But whatever the case, just delete the photo. Then he goes down into the parking lot and he starts playing his steel drum again. It's a very wintry parking lot, too. Like the trees are covered in snow, but he's determined to play the only thing he knows,
大新闻。是的，迈克尔非常纠结。好吧，我想我们也许该休息一下。等我们回来，我们会弄清楚迈克尔将如何解决这个问题，看看这个夏威夷派对到底办不办得成。好的，我们回来了。迈克尔在办公室里宣布了一个消息，告诉大家必须删掉这张照片，那不是简。可能是简，但不是简。不管怎样，总之把照片删了。然后他走到停车场，又开始弹他的钢鼓。这也是个非常寒冷的停车场。就像树上覆盖着雪，但他决心只弹他唯一会的一首歌，
which is feeling hot, hot, hot. Yes. And only one note from that song can he play on the steel drum. But I'm really glad that you mentioned the weather, Angela, because we had to set all of that up. We shot this in October, but of course this aired in the middle of winter. So we wanted to make sure that our seasons on the show coordinated with what would actually be happening in Scranton, Pennsylvania at the time. And it was my idea to not come all the way out the door. I said, Pam doesn't have her coat on. I think if this were really me, I would just sort of hover inside and kind of talk through a crack in the door when it's really cold. And I just love that that made that in. They liked that idea. And so that's why Pam doesn't come all the way
那就是《感觉好热，热，热》。是的。而且他只能用钢鼓弹出那首歌的一个音符。但我真的很高兴你提到了天气，安吉拉，因为我们必须把那些都布置好。我们在十月拍摄的，但当然这在冬天中期播出。所以我们要确保剧中的季节与当时宾夕法尼亚州斯克兰顿实际发生的情况相协调。而且我的主意是不要完全走到门外。我说，潘没穿外套。我想如果这真的是我，当天气真的很冷的时候，我可能只会缩在里面，透过门缝说话。我太喜欢这个被采纳了。他们喜欢这个主意。所以这就是为什么潘没有完全走到
outside to talk to Michael. Oh, I loved that. I didn't know that, but it felt very real to me that you'd be like, Hey, idiot, come inside. Can I confess something? Yeah, I really love when I get to pretend to be cold. Really? Yeah, because I'm cold all the time. I feel like I have such a full suitcase of material to pull from when I need to be cold. I'm cold constantly. And so that's why I was like, Oh, you need me to pretend to be cold? Well, I'll tell you what I would do. I wouldn't walk all the way outside without a coat on. Let me throw that atcha. And there was like, there was an episode, a few episodes ago, where we were all in the parking lot, we were pretending to be cold. And I saw myself, I kept putting my mouth down into the front of my coat
外面去跟迈克尔说话。哦，我太喜欢那个了。我当时不知道，但我觉得非常真实，你会说：“嘿，笨蛋，进来吧。”我能坦白一件事吗？行，我真的很喜欢假装很冷的时候。真的吗？对啊，因为我一直都很冷。我觉得当我需要表现得很冷时，我有满满一箱的素材可以调用。我经常觉得冷。所以这就是为什么我想，“哦，你需要我假装很冷吗？好吧，我告诉你我会怎么做。我才不会不穿外套就走到外面去呢。让我这么跟你说吧。”还有就像，有那么一集，几集之前，我们都在停车场里，我们假装很冷。我看到自己，我一直把嘴塞进外套领口里
and breathing into it, because that's something I do when I'm cold. I'm noticing all of my cold detail acting, and I'm really proud of it. So I'm giving a little flex to it right now. All your cold stick, you've got your cold shirt down. I own a sweatshirt that says always cold that my family gave to me as a gift, because I drive everyone crazy. I sneak up behind and turn the thermostat off like I'm that person. So Jenna, I don't know if I'm great at pretending to be cold, but I'm with you. I mean, you and I froze our butts off on that set. So now we're at the Luau. Angela Martin is cutting up spam, because- I guess that's all you could get. You couldn't get a full pig from the petting zoo, as you had told Phyllis. Oh, Lord. Well, my dad loves spam. So when I saw
对着它呼气，因为那是我冷的时候会做的事。我注意到了我所有的抗寒细节演技，而且我为此感到非常骄傲。所以我现在要小小地显摆一下。你所有的抗寒老把戏，你的抗寒衬衫都准备好了。我有一件印着“总是很冷”的卫衣，是我家人送我的礼物，因为我把所有人都快逼疯了。我会偷偷溜到后面把恒温器关掉，就像我就是那种人一样。所以珍娜，我不知道我假装怕冷的技术是不是很好，但我跟你一样。我的意思是，你和我那个布景上都快冻成冰棍了。所以现在我们到了夏威夷派对。安吉拉·马丁正在切午餐肉罐头，因为——我想那是你能弄到的全部了。你没办法像对菲利斯说的那样，从宠物动物园弄来整整一头猪。哦，天哪。好吧，我爸爸很喜欢午餐肉。所以当我看到
that, I just got tickled, because it made me think of my dad. My mom was really in charge of all the cooking and meal prep when I was growing up, unless it was barbecuing, like they were so traditional. My dad, like, manned the barbecue. But if my mom, and it was very rare, but let's say my mom woke up and she was like, oh, gosh, I have a cold. I have a fever. You know, whatever, one of those mornings where my dad had to take over, my dad would fry spam. And we'd all be like, ah, and he'd be like, you're going to have spam. And then he would fry it up for breakfast. And then if he had to make our lunch, he'd be like, well, we got leftover spam. It was like, Dad, so much spam. What is spam? I think spam's a lot of parts. Does it have flavors in it? Is it a specific
那个时，我一下子就被逗乐了，因为它让我想起了我爸爸。我长大的时候，我妈妈真的负责所有的做饭和备餐，除非是烧烤，他们太传统了。我爸爸，就像，掌管烧烤。但如果我妈妈，虽然这很少见，但假设我妈妈醒来说，哦，天哪，我感冒了。我发烧了。你知道的，诸如此类的早晨，我爸爸必须接手，我爸爸就会炸午餐肉。然后我们都会说，啊，而他会说，你们得吃午餐肉。然后他会把它炸了当早餐。然后如果他得给我们做午饭，他就会说，好吧，我们有剩下的午餐肉。就像是，爸爸，怎么这么多午餐肉。什么是午餐肉？我觉得午餐肉有很多部分组成的。它有味道吗？它是某种特定
flavor? It's very salty. Okay, wait, we're getting a message from Cody. This is the benefit of zooming our podcast. Our producer can pop on. She is telling us that spam's basic ingredients are, quote, pork with ham added, saltwater, modified potato starch as a binder, sugar and sodium nitrate as a preservative. There is also a natural gelatin that is formed during cooking in its tins on the production line. Cody's clarifying, ham is from the pig's hind leg while pork is any meat from pigs. Wait, guys, the spam conversation is not over. I know you were worried that we were stopping the spam conversation, but Sam just threw down that there are 15 different flavors of spam. Okay, well, that seems crazy. It's what you're here for, guys. It's what you're
的味道吗？非常咸。好吧，等等，我们收到一条来自科迪的信息。这就是我们进行播客视频连线的益处。我们的制作人可以跳出来。她告诉我们，午餐肉的基本成分是，引述，“加入了火腿的猪肉、盐水、作为粘合剂的改性马铃薯淀粉、糖以及作为防腐剂的亚硝酸钠。”生产线上在罐头里烹饪时还会形成一种天然明胶。科迪澄清说，火腿来自猪的后腿，而猪肉是猪身上的任何肉。等等，伙计们，关于午餐肉的讨论还没结束呢。我知道你们担心我们要停下关于午餐肉的讨论，但萨姆刚刚抛出消息说午餐肉有15种不同的口味。好吧，那听起来太疯狂了。这就是你们来这里的目的，伙计们。这就是你们
here for. It's what you're here for. All right. Well, so yes, we're back to the luau in the warehouse. Jim gives Karen some papers. What are they, Jenna? Yes, he hands her a rental agreement for the apartment that is two blocks away from him. And they're so happy and they make up. You know, Angela, we got a lot of questions about why are they having this luau down in the warehouse. People were kind of confused. And I think that's because there were a bunch of scenes that got deleted from this section of the show that remind you that we're supposed to be doing inventory down there. There are so many deleted scenes from the warehouse. So there were all of these little vignettes. One of the ones I loved was that Ryan is staring at a bunch of boxes
来这里的目的。这就是你们来这里的目的。好吧。所以是的，我们回到了仓库里的夏威夷派对。吉姆给凯伦一些文件。那是什么，珍娜？是的，他递给她一份公寓的租赁协议，那套公寓离他只有两个街区远。他们太高兴了，然后和好了。你知道的，安吉拉，我们收到了很多关于为什么他们在仓库里办这个夏威夷派对的问题。大家有点困惑。我想那是因为这一段有很多场景被删掉了，那些场景提醒大家，我们其实是应该在下面盘点库存的。仓库里有太多被删掉的场景了。所以有所有这些小片段。我最喜欢的一个是雷恩盯着一堆箱子
and he has like a clicker in his hand, like, you know, that you would check off like a barcode, like beep, beep. And Roy walks up and goes, what's the problem? And Ryan's like, well, we're seven boxes short of whatever yellow paper, whatever it was. And Roy just takes the clicker from Ryan and then just scans into the air like seven, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep. And he goes fixed. So there's like, and Ryan's like, oh, so we're not doing, we're just fudging it. But like, there's all these different moments within the warehouse that are happening that remind you that we're actually there to do inventory. Then another deleted scene that happens is Meredith is doing inventory and she's trying to get to one of the
手里拿个扫码器，就像你知道的那样，你可以核对条形码的那种，比如哔、哔。然后罗伊走过来问，有什么问题吗？雷恩就说，嗯，某种黄纸我们少了好几箱，不管是什么纸吧。然后罗伊直接从雷恩手里拿过扫码器，对着空气扫了起来，就像“哔、哔、哔、哔、哔、哔、哔、哔、哔、哔、哔、哔”。然后他说搞定。所以这里有，然后雷恩说，哦，所以我们不用盘，我们只是在胡弄。但是，仓库里发生了所有这些不同的时刻，提醒你其实我们是在那里盘点库存的。然后另一个被删掉的场景是梅雷迪思正在盘点库存，她正试图拿到货架顶上的一个
boxes on top of the shelf. And she does that thing, you guys, I have done so many times, especially in a grocery store, when I can't reach something on the top, I climb up the bottom of the shelf and she does this and the whole entire shelf comes crashing down on her head with all the boxes. She's completely buried. If you watch the deleted scenes, you can't even see Kate anymore. She's buried. No one notices. People just keep on business as usual. And then you hear this muffled voice say, hello, I'm stuck. We got a fan question about this moment. Jess Moore wrote in and said, did Kate Flannery do her own stunt and that deleted scene in the warehouse? Well, Jess, we reached out to Kate and this is what she had to say.
箱子。她做了那个动作，伙计们，我做过好多次了，特别是在杂货店里，当我够不到高处的东西时，我就往货架底部爬，她就是这么做的，然后整个货架轰然倒塌砸在她头上，上面所有的箱子也砸了下来。她被完全埋在下面了。如果你看被删掉的场景，你甚至都看不到凯特了。她被埋了。根本没人注意到。大家只是照常做生意。然后你会听到一个闷声闷气的声音说：“喂，我被卡住了。”我们收到了一个关于这个时刻的粉丝提问。杰斯·莫尔写信说：“凯特·弗兰纳里在仓库那个被删掉的场景里是自己完成的特技吗？”好吧，杰斯，我们联系了凯特，以下是她的说法：
Hey, Office Ladies podcast fans. It's me, Kate Flannery, Meredith from the office. Yes, I did a lot of my own stunts. I kind of got the idea that as much physical comedy as I could do, I was going to do. I said yes to a lot of my stunts, even though I know that there was a stunt double there that day. Debbie Evans, but they did not use her, happened several times. I think the stunt people still got paid, and I never went to the hospital. So who cares, right? But yeah, we sort of perfected things. By the time Meredith gets hit by the car in season four, we were really off to the races. So this episode, this stunt was kind of the beginnings of my bravery. So thanks for watching.
嘿，办公室女士播客的粉丝们。我是凯特·弗兰纳里，办公室里的梅雷迪思。是的，我的很多特技都是自己完成的。我当时有一种想法，就是能做多少肢体喜剧，我就尽量做多少。我对我的很多特技都说“好”，尽管我知道那天现场有一个特技替身。黛比·埃文斯，但他们没有用她，这种情况发生好几次。我想特技演员们还是拿到了报酬，而且我从来没进过医院。所以谁在乎呢，对吧？但真的，我们把事情做得越来越完美。等到第四季梅雷迪思被车撞的时候，我们真的是全速前进了。所以这一集，这个特技算是我的勇敢的开端。所以谢谢观看。
She's fearless. She really is. That is insane. I mean, she is fearless. If you go and watch that deleted scene, truly a whole entire shelf full of stuff falls on her and you can't even see her. She's fearless. I would have been like, Debbie, I'm going to need you. I'm going to need you in. Debbie, get on in here because there is no way I would have done that. No way. I am too much of a scaredy cat. You know what's interesting is that one of the things I really wanted to do on this show, I don't know why. I think I think I'm a badass driver. I'm probably not, but I always wanted to do all my driving stunts. And when they let me, because Dwight and I have a few driving scenes, I would get really excited. Don't want to do those either. I like it when they hook it up
她无所畏惧。她真的是。太疯狂了。我的意思是，她无所畏惧。如果你去看那个被删掉的场景，真的整整一货架的东西都砸在她身上，你甚至都看不到她。她无所畏惧。换作我就会说：“黛比，我需要你。我需要你上场。”黛比，快上，因为我是绝对不会那样做的。绝对不会。我太胆小了。你知道有趣的是，我在这个剧里真正想做的一件事，我不知道为什么。我想，我想我是一个很棒的车手。我可能不是，但我一直想做所有的驾驶特技。当他们让我去拍时，因为我和德怀特有几个驾驶场景，我会觉得非常兴奋。其实我也不想拍那些。我喜欢他们把车
to a rig and pull the car. I'm like, I don't want to drive this down the road while I'm acting. No one wants that. I've had to do that before. I'm always terrified. Well, one thing that did make it into the scene is this very odd moment of Darrell finding his iPod. And I want you to know that is not in the script. That was an improvisation by Craig on the day. He actually found an iPod deck and speaker somewhere back in the warehouse. And he just did this bit and it made it into the show. And it is so funny to me. We got so much mail about it. People are like, is there something I'm missing? Is there a deleted scene from a previous episode where Darrell loses his iPod? Is this product placement for iPod again? No,
固定在拖车架上拉着走的那种。我会觉得，我可不想边演戏边把车开在路上。没人想那样。我以前不得不拍过那种戏。我总是吓得要死。好吧，有一件事确实剪进了正片，就是达里尔找到他的iPod这个非常古怪的时刻。我想让你们知道，剧本里根本没有这个。那是克雷格当天即兴发挥的。他实际上在仓库的某个地方找到了一个iPod底座和扬声器。他就即兴演了这段，然后被剪进了正片。这对我来说太搞笑了。我们收到了好多关于这个的信。大家都在问，我是不是漏掉了什么？前几集里是不是有一个被删掉的场景，讲的是达里尔弄丢了他的iPod？这又是iPod的植入广告吗？不，
it was just this random funny bit. He does it with such like real enthusiasm. Well, we had to be there pretending like we were going through boxes, guys. So we were really doing stuff, which you don't really see. It didn't really make it into the show. But I think that he legitimately opened up a box and that was in there and he got all excited. Yes, exactly. Well, I have a little Angela Roy moment that happens right at the same time. At 14 minutes, 44 seconds, you can see Angela starts to walk up to Roy and is about to like go up to him. And then Darrell yells, I found an iPod dock and I whip my head and I pivot the other way. Wow. You have to go and watch it. More of the untold Angela Roy story. And I'm wondering, I mean,
这只是一个随机的搞笑段落。他演得充满了真实的热情。好吧，我们在那儿得假装我们在翻箱倒柜，伙计们。所以我们确实在干活，虽然你其实看不出来。它并没有真正剪进正片里。但我认为他是合法地打开了一个箱子，里面正好有那个，然后他就兴奋起来了。是的，完全如此。好吧，我在几乎同一时间还有一个安吉拉和罗伊的小互动。在14分44秒时，你可以看到安吉拉开始朝罗伊走去，正准备朝他走过去。然后达里尔大喊：“我找到一个iPod底座了！”然后我猛地一扭头，转向了另一个方向。哇。你们得去看看。更多安吉拉和罗伊不为人知的故事。我在想，我的意思是，
what was meant to happen there? Like, it's not in the script. It's not in deleted scenes. But I'm sure I was given some direction maybe to go over and, you know, in the background, sort of talk to Roy. But yeah, when Darrell yells, I turn around and go the other direction. It's a fun little catch. Well, then we see Pam is doing some inventory and Karen comes up to her and thanks her. She says, thank you so much for talking sense into Jim. Karen is so happy. Her relationship is back on. Everything's okay. And then we cut to Pam just sobbing on a bench in the hallway. And Angela, I watched this scene and it just brought tears to my eyes because I remember shooting it so clearly, so clearly. And we got a lot of questions about it.
那里原本打算发生什么？这不在剧本里。也不在被删掉的场景里。但我确信我当时得到了一些指导，也许是走过去，你知道的，在背景里，和罗伊说说话。但当达里尔大喊时，我转过身朝另一个方向走去。这是一个有趣的小细节。好吧，然后我们看到潘在盘点库存，凯伦向她走来并向她道谢。她说：“非常感谢你劝醒了吉姆。”凯伦太高兴了。他们的关系复合了。一切都好。然后镜头切到潘独自一人坐在走廊的长椅上泣不成声。安吉拉，我看到这一幕时，眼泪夺眶而出，因为我记得拍摄它的情景是如此清晰，如此清晰。我们收到了很多关于它的问题。
So we got questions from Joe Salazar, Angie Letworth, Elisa Goldman, Jillian Riley, and Charlie Sparkenbaugh. They wanted to know, how was it filming that iconic Pam and Dwight scene when Pam is crying? Well, guys, this was like early on in the show. And whenever we had these really emotional scenes like that parking lot scene with Jim and Pam, we would just kind of shut down everything. And I remember that we shut down the set. And we took hours prepping and shooting this crying scene. It was really important to Greg that I really be crying. They did not want to put fake tears in my eyes. He wanted me to really go there. And this is a really big challenge for an actor. And so what they did was they made everything
所以我们收到了来自乔·萨拉萨尔、安吉·莱特沃思、伊莉莎·戈德曼、吉莉安·莱利和查理·斯帕肯鲍的提问。他们想知道，拍摄潘在哭的那场标志性的潘和德怀特戏时是怎样的？好吧，伙计们，这是在剧集早期。每当有像吉姆和潘在停车场那样的非常情绪化的戏时，我们就会把一切都关掉。我记得我们关闭了片场。我们花了几个小时来筹备和拍摄这场哭戏。对格雷格来说，让我真正哭出来非常重要。他们不想在我的眼里滴假眼泪。他希望我能真正融入进去。这对演员来说是一个巨大的挑战。所以他们所做的是，他们让一切变得
really quiet. And no one talked to me for about a half hour. And I put on the saddest music I could find. And it was sad because it was personal to me, right? It was music that brought up memories of breakups, music that I listened to at different times in my life when I was having a particularly hard time. So it would bring up a lot of emotions. And I had spent the previous week creating this playlist, because I knew that it would invoke a lot of emotion. And I sat and I listened to it until I was crying. And then Kelly, our first AD came and took the headphones away from me. And then they started rolling. And that's how they were able to begin the scene with me crying. Because when you play a scene, Angela, and you have dialogue,
非常安静。大概有半个小时没有人跟我说话。我播放了我能找到的最悲伤的音乐。它之所以悲伤，是因为它对我有私人意义，对吧？那是能勾起分手回忆的音乐，是我在生活中经历特别艰难时期时在不同时间听的音乐。所以它会勾起很多情绪。我花了一个星期的时间制作这个播放列表，因为我知道它会唤起很多情感。我坐在那里听着它，直到我哭出来。然后凯利，我们的第一助理导演过来拿走了我的耳机。接着他们开始开机了。这就是他们能够让我带着哭腔开始这场戏的原因。因为当你演一场戏时，安吉拉，你有台词，
and you have connection with a person, a lot of times that will bring the emotion out of you. But it's really hard to start a scene in a full cry, because you would just have to get yourself there. No, that's so true. It's actually really hard because you're basically taking yourself emotionally from zero to 60. And I had to do a crying scene in a show called Haters Back Off that was like something in the middle. And I remember they let me sort of, sort of just step away from set to get myself there. And once I was there, they started rolling. I took this acting class, and it was talking about emotional journeys. And the acting teacher encouraged us to pick a song, one song, because sometimes on set, you don't have the luxury of being able to
你和一个有人际连接，很多时候这会把你的情绪激发出来。但要在一场戏一开始就全哭出来真的很难，因为你必须自己把自己带到那种状态。不，太对了。其实真的很难，因为你基本上是在情感上从零瞬间飙到六十。我在一个叫《讨厌鬼滚开》的剧里拍过一场哭戏，那是一种介于中间的东西。我记得他们让我稍微，稍微离开片场一会儿来调整状态。一旦我进入状态，他们就开机了。我上过一个表演课，里面谈到了情感之旅。表演老师鼓励我们选一首歌，一首歌，因为有时在片场，你没有奢侈的时间去
like go listen. That really shows how much our show was taking care of you in that moment, I feel like. Yeah. But sometimes you only have a few minutes to reset yourself emotionally and to get to that place. So we took, everyone picked one song. And in your mind, you sing that one song, and by the end of that song, you should be in that emotional place. And it really worked for me. And I find for myself now, I'm older now, guys, I'm 49. And more life has happened to me. And it's easier for me to get to that place than when I was a younger actor. Yeah, same. But music is a big way to trigger it for me. And I think for a lot of actors, I've created musical soundtracks for a lot of things I've done. I had to do a play, and I had to start out the play in a rage. I had to
走开去听歌。这真的显示了我们的剧组在那一刻是多么照顾你，我觉得。是的。但有时你只有几分钟时间来重置你的情绪并到达那个地方。所以我们每个人都选了一首歌。在你的脑海里，你唱那首歌，到那首歌结束时，你应该就进入那种情感状态了。这对我真的很管用。我发现对我自己来说，我现在老了，伙计们，我49岁了。我经历了更多的人生。对我来说，要达到那种状态比我年轻时当演员要容易。是的，我也是。但音乐对我来说是触发它的重要途径。我想对于很多演员来说，我为我做过的很多事情都创作过音乐原声带。我必须演一集话剧，我必须在愤怒中开场。我必须
start out very, very angry. And I couldn't find a song that exactly triggered my anger. I had a song that would kind of amp me up. And then I realized I had some audio of an ex-boyfriend who I, like, really was pissed at still to this day. I found this audio tape and I played his voice. And it made me so damn mad that I would, you can hear me right now just thinking about it. It made me so damn mad that I could just walk out on stage and start screaming at the other actor on stage because just his voice triggered me. Wow. So I think they're, you know, music, something you can listen to. Yeah, that works. Yeah, I think that goes, I mean, you guys listening, you can, I know there are songs that take you right back to a moment in your life. That's, that's the power
一开始就非常非常愤怒。我找不到一首能准确触发我愤怒的歌。我有一首能让我兴奋起来的歌。然后我意识到我有一些前男友的音频，我，你知道的，直到今天我还是很生他的气。我找到了这个音频磁带，播放了他的声音。这让我气得要命，你现在听到我脑子里想起来就知道了。这让我气得要命，以至于我可以直接走上舞台，开始对台上的另一个演员大喊大叫，因为仅仅是他的声音就触发了我。哇。所以我觉得，你知道的，音乐，你可以听点什么。是的，那管用。是的，我觉得那是，我的意思是，你们听众，你们可以，我知道有些歌能把你瞬间带回生活中的那一刻。那才是
and beauty of music, right? The song that like would make me tear up by the end is a lefty fizzle song called That's the Way Love Goes. So, and it's an old song. Some of you will know it. Some of you in this moment know that I'm 100 years old because it's a really old song. Well, one of the songs I was listening to to help make me cry for Pam was a Benfold song. But I had a whole Pam soundtrack that I would listen to on my drive to work during season three when her and Jim were estranged. And it was Nora Jones. Lady, she's just so soulful and wishing and a little lost. I remember you guys doing the scene and I remember it from the filter of your BFF. And I remember you were really anxious about it. You really wanted to get it right.
音乐的力量和美妙之处，对吧？那首最后能让我落泪的歌是一首老歌，莱蒂·菲泽尔的《爱就是这样》。所以，这是一首老歌。你们中的有些人会知道。你们中的一些人此时会知道我已经100岁了，因为它真的是一首老歌。好吧，我当时听的用来帮我为潘哭泣的歌之一是本·福尔斯的歌。但在第三季她和吉姆疏远期间，我开车去上班时，我有一整张潘的专属原声带。那是诺拉·琼斯。天哪，她的歌声太深情了，带着渴望又有点迷茫。我记得你们拍这场戏的情景，我是透过你们闺蜜的视角来回忆的。我记得你当时真的很焦虑。你真的很想把它演好。
You were doing all the prep. I remember when you guys went to do the scene that I left you alone. You know, you don't need your chatty five foot one. I was like, I'm going to give her all the space she needs and rewatching it. Jenna, it made me tear up. It's so beautiful. And I think I see rain as Dwight tearing up. But surely Dwight wouldn't tear up. But I think rain, your friend, is tearing up watching you cry. Angela, it's making me get choked up when you say it because this is a little bit of a place where the line blurred between the rain that you and I know and Dwight rain simply couldn't do that scene without empathizing with Pam. Every time we did a take, he teared up when I cried harder. It was like rain. Wilson, the man was incapable of sitting
你做了所有的准备工作。我记得当你们去拍那场戏时，我离开你了，让你独自一人。你知道的，你不需要你那个啰嗦的五尺一寸高的朋友。我想：“我要给她所有她需要的空间。”重看的时候，珍娜，我看得眼泪都流出来了。太美了。而且我想我看到雷恩作为德怀特也在落泪。但德怀特肯定不会哭的吧。不过我想雷恩，作为你的朋友，看着你哭他在落泪。安吉拉，你这么一说让我觉得哽咽了，因为这在某种程度上模糊了你我认识的雷恩和德怀特的界限，雷恩根本无法在不同情潘的情况下演完那场戏。每次我们拍一条，当我哭得更厉害时，他就会跟着落泪。就像雷恩·威尔逊这个人在坐在
next to a person in pain without feeling their pain. And this is the thing that we know about rain. It's the thing that we love about rain. And when I saw it in the scene, it just made me miss rain so much because that's who rain is to me on a personal level. Yeah. Yeah, I just saw rain. I just saw him and he's tearing up. And then he has to snap back to Dwight, you know, and say the line or, you know, PMSing pretty hard, right? Yes. One of my favorite things he does in the scene as Dwight is he takes his jacket off and you're positive he's going to wrap it around Pam and he ties it around his waist so awkwardly. Yes, that was in the script. That's the other thing. All the little beats, all the moments, him putting his jacket around his waist, giving the
一个痛苦的人旁边时，是不可能不感受到对方的痛苦的。这就是我们了解的雷恩，也是我们爱雷恩的地方。当我在戏里看到这一幕时，它让我太想念雷恩了，因为在个人层面上，这就是雷恩对我的意义。是的。是的，我刚才看到雷恩了。我看到他眼泪汪汪的。然后他必须迅速切换回德怀特状态，你知道的，说那句台词，或者，“来大姨妈挺难受的吧，对吧？”是的。他在那场戏里演德怀特时我最喜欢的动作之一，就是他脱下夹克，你绝对以为他要把夹克披在潘身上，结果他却极其别扭地把它系在腰上。是的，剧本里就是这么写的。这就是另一回事了。所有的这些小节拍，所有的时刻，他把夹克系在腰上，递
handkerchief, awkwardly putting his arm around her shoulder, all of that is scripted all those moments. It's just it was a beautifully written scene. And they gave us great time to figure it out and shoot it. I'm really proud of that scene. It's one of my favorites from the series that I got to do. I know you just did it so well. Where are we now? Well, Jan has arrived. Oh, it's so awkward. Jan has arrived and you could you could cut the tension even though we were acting. I remember Malora has such a presence and when she walked into that warehouse, it was like you could hear a pin drop even though we knew we were acting. It just was a powerful moment. Yes. And Michael's slow walk up the stairs was so good. So good. So good. And then Jenna,
手帕，笨拙地把胳膊搭在她肩膀上，所有这些在剧本里都是写好的。那是一个写得非常精彩的场景。他们给了我们充足的时间来琢磨和拍摄它。我为那场戏感到非常自豪。这是我演过的剧集里最喜欢的场景之一。我知道，你演得太棒了。我们现在在哪？好吧，简到了。哦，太尴尬了。简到了，哪怕我们在演戏，你也能感受到那股紧张气氛。我记得玛洛拉气场太强了，当她走进那个仓库时，感觉就像掉根针都能听见，尽管我们知道是在演戏。那真是一个充满力量的时刻。是的。而且迈克尔慢吞吞地走上楼梯太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。然后珍娜，
when they get back to Michael's office, what a power move Jan is sitting in his seat. He has to sit across from her where the other employees would normally sit. It was so badass. I so loved it. So now in this scene, you don't know what's going to happen. You're pretty sure that she knows about this picture and she has come to just lay into Michael about sending out this photo. But she's either unaware of the photo or she doesn't care because she tells Michael this amazing speech. It's so amazing. It's so good. She says her therapist thinks she has self-destructive tendencies and she should just lean into them. Let's try that for a change. Let's just go with the destruction. I love it. She says in this past year, I have been through a
当他们回到迈克尔的办公室时，简坐在他的座位上，这真是个权力宣示。他不得不坐在平时其他员工坐的对面。这太霸气了。我太喜欢了。所以在这个场景里，你不知道会发生什么。你很确信她知道这张照片的事，她来这里就是要大骂迈克尔到处发这张照片。但她要么不知道这张照片，要么根本不在乎，因为她对迈克尔说了一段精彩绝伦的台词。太棒了。太棒了。她说她的心理医生认为她有自我毁灭倾向，她应该顺应这种倾向。咱们这次换个方式试试。我们就顺着毁灭来吧。我太喜欢了。她说在过去的一年里，我经历了一场
divorce and identity theft and identity theft. She's like, my ex-husband, you know, canter won't share his feelings with me. And then she says, maybe she will find happiness by lowering her expectations and following her instinct to be with Michael. Everything in Melora's performance is perfection. And then it is mirrored by Steve's perfect reactions to everything she's saying. He is confused. He isn't sure if he can be happy. He's clearly like afraid to react. Yeah, he's frozen because he's like, she's breaking up with me. Wait, she's not? Which she likes me. Oh, but she's leaving me. Who's this therapist? What's happening? It's like, all of those things are happening. And then, you know, she grabs them and gives
离婚和身份盗窃。她就像是，我的前夫，你知道的，坎特不肯跟我分享他的感受。然后她说，也许她可以通过降低期望值并顺从自己想要和迈克尔在一起的本能来找到幸福。玛洛拉的表演完美无瑕。紧接着是史蒂夫对她所说的一切作出的完美反应。他很困惑。他不确定自己能不能幸福。他显然一副不敢作出反应的样子。是的，他僵住了，因为他觉得，“她在跟我分手吗？等等，没有？她喜欢我。哦，但她要离开我。这心理医生是谁？发生什么事了？”就像，所有这些事情都在脑子里过。然后，你知道的，她一把抓住他，
them a big sloppy kiss. I wrote on my card, Jan hashtag DGAF. What's DGAF? Don't give a f***. Oh, because she knows the camber crew is there. She is clearly over it. She's like, I'm going to lean into this. Just like my doctor said, she says, meet me back at your condo in 15 minutes. And then it's my favorite moment. I mean, well, there's many favorite moments, but this is one of my favorite moments. He's stunned. And he looks at her and says, you complete me, like from Jerry Maguire, like that scene in the elevator. He's like, you complete me. And she looks at him and pauses. It's such a wonderful pause. And she goes, oh, God. All of that was scripted, Angela. Oh, it's so good. It says that he says that line. And
狠狠地、湿漉漉地亲了他一口。我在我的卡片上写下：简，标签“根本不在乎”（#DGAF）。什么是DGAF？根本不在乎（Don't give a f***）。哦，因为她知道坎特团队的人都在那儿。她显然已经不在乎了。她就像是，我要顺应这个。就像我医生说的，她说：“15分钟内在你的公寓见我。”然后这是我最喜欢的时刻。我的意思是，有很多最喜欢的时刻，但这绝对是其中之一。他惊呆了。他看着她说：“你完整了我”（You complete me），就像《甜心先生》里电梯里的那一幕。他就像是，“你完整了我。”而她看着他，停顿了一下。那是一个多么美妙的停顿。然后她说：“哦，天哪。”所有这些都是剧本里写好的，安吉拉。哦，太棒了。剧本里写着他说那句台词，
then it says Jan pauses and then sighs. But she's like, still going to meet him at his apartment. Yeah, that Oh, God is like, well, I'm in it now. Lady, we got a fan question about this scene that's so intrigued me. Listen to this. Okay, this is from Nilly. Nilly said Daniel Levinson and Roger Gould are adult developmental psychologists who have contributed massively to the field, including the study and definition of the midlife crisis. Is Jan Levinson Gould's name a reference to the fact that she is the epitome of a midlife crisis? Or is it just a coincidence? That is an amazing catch. I think it's a coincidence because I don't think they knew that the character of Jan was going to become what she
然后写着简停顿了一下，然后叹了口气。但她还是会去他的公寓见他。是的，那个“哦，天哪”的意思就像是，好吧，我算是陷进去了。女士们，我们收到一个关于这个场景的粉丝提问，太吸引我了。听听这个。好吧，这是尼利（Nilly）发来的。尼利说，丹尼尔·莱文森（Daniel Levinson）和罗杰·古尔德（Roger Gould）是成年发展心理学家，他们对该领域做出了巨大贡献，包括对中年危机研究和定义。简·莱文森·古尔德（Jan Levinson Gould）的名字是在暗示她是中年危机的化身吗？还是这只是个巧合？这是一个了不起的发现。我觉得这只是个巧合，因为我不认为他们在一开始就知道简这个角色会变成后来的样子。
was when we started. So when they named her Jan Levinson Gould, they were not aware that she was going to spin out and go down this road with Michael yet that that happened over time. But I will tell you that I appreciate this fan letter, because it sent me down a fabulous two hour rabbit hole where I googled Dr. Roger Gould adult development theory. Fascinating. I'd like you to know that you can also get a book called the seasons of a man's life by Dr. Daniel Levinson. But all of their work was combined into a wonderful book by Gail Sheehy. She's a feminist journalist and she wrote passages predictable crises of adult life. Did I buy all these books and I'm waiting for them? Maybe I did, Nilly. Maybe I did. I'll report back. But guys, if you
所以当他们给她取名简·莱文森·古尔德时，他们并不知道她会失控并和迈克尔走上这条路，那是随着时间推移发生的。但我必须说，我很感激这封粉丝来信，因为它让我开启了一段美妙的两小时知识搜索之旅，我去谷歌搜索了“罗杰·古尔德博士的成人发展理论”。太迷人了。我想让你们知道，你还可以买到一本丹尼尔·莱文森博士写的书，叫《男人一生的四季》。但他们所有的工作都被盖尔·希伊（Gail Sheehy）结合到了一本精彩的书里。她是一位女性主义记者，她写了《成年期可预测的危机》。我是不是把这些书都买下来了，正在等它们送货？也许是的，尼利。也许是的。我回头向大家汇报。但伙计们，如果你
want to go on the journey with me, you can Google it all. It was really awesome. Jenna, I love this so much because you and I do our prep separately. So I don't know the rabbit holes you're going down. You're doing that. And I spent half an hour looking up different flavors of jelly beans. It's all good. It's all important. It's all important. Well, you know, so we go back to the luau. It's not going great. People look like they're having a pretty lame time. And there's a scene between Roy and Pam. And he kind of cheers her up. Yeah. Yeah. Roy says, remember how we were deciding where to go on the honeymoon? You wanted Hawaii. I wanted Mexico. Well, I was right. So I think he's sort of saying that Mexico would be better than Hawaii because this luau's lame. I
想跟我一起踏上这段旅程，你们可以自己去谷歌搜索。真的太棒了。珍娜，我太喜欢这个了，因为你和我是分开做准备工作的。所以我不知道你在研究什么冷门知识。你在做那个，而我花了半个小时查找不同口味的果冻豆。这都很好。这都很重要。这都很重要。好吧，你知道的，所以我们回到了夏威夷派对。情况不太妙。大家看起来过得很无聊。然后罗伊和潘之间有一场戏。他算是把她逗开心了。是的。是的，罗伊说：“还记得我们当时怎么决定去哪里度蜜月的吗？你想要夏威夷，我想要墨西哥。你看，我是对的。”所以我想他的意思是墨西哥比夏威夷好，因为这个夏威夷派对太无聊了。我
don't track his reasoning. But Pam laughs. And I think she really needed that laugh. Yeah. This was the first moment where we show that like Pam is being comforted by Roy. So all along, we've been seeing Roy try to make these gestures reaching out to her. And this one lands. And this was kind of going to maybe put Pam and Roy back on track. Well, before we wrap up back from vacation, Jenna, I have one deleted scene. It's a Michael talking head. And I have to share it with you, because it really sums up Michael's state of mind as he comes back from Jamaica. All right, I got to hear this. What is it? So Michael is driving in his car to work. It's his first day back to work from Jamaica, driving in his car talking head. He says,
理解不了他的逻辑。但潘笑了。我觉得她真的很需要那个笑。是的。这是我们第一次展现出潘正在被罗伊安慰。所以一路上，我们一直看到罗伊试图做出这些示好的举动来接近她。而这一次成功了。这大概会让潘和罗伊重新回到正轨上。好吧，在我们结束假期回来之前，珍娜，我有一个被删掉的场景。这是一个迈克尔的单采镜头。我必须跟你分享，因为它真的很总结迈克尔从牙买加回来时的心态。好吧，我得听听这个。是什么？所以迈克尔开车去上班。这是他从牙买加度假回来的第一天，他在车里边开车边做单采。他说，
you know how they say take a chill pill? In Jamaica, I took one guy on the beach sold it to me for $40. And after I finished vomiting, I was more relaxed than I've ever been. I lost six pounds too. And that's how I want every day to be. Yeah, he wants to take a pill, vomit his brains out, then be relaxed, and then have a pina colada at three o'clock. Yeah. Amazing. Amazing. Well, guys, that was back from vacation. Yes. Thank you so much for sending in your questions. And a big thank you to Kim Ferry. You can find her on Instagram at HairFerry.Kim. That's H-A-I-R F-E-R-R-Y.Kim. She posts so many fun behind the scenes things from all the projects she's worked on, including the office. And Kate Flannery, thank you so much for your audio clip. I asked Kate
你知道他们说的吃颗冷静丸是什么意思吗？在牙买加，我吃了一颗，海滩上一个家伙卖给我的，40美元。等我吐完之后，我比以往任何时候都放松。我还瘦了六磅。我希望每天都这样。是的，他想吃药，吐个底朝天，然后放松下来，三点钟再来一杯皮娜科达鸡品。太棒了。太棒了。好吧，伙计们，那就是“度假归来”。是的。非常感谢大家发来你们的问题。非常感谢金·费里（Kim Ferry）。你可以在Instagram上找到她，账号是 HairFerry.Kim。也就是 H-A-I-R F-E-R-R-Y.Kim。她发布了许多关于她参与过的所有项目的幕后趣事，包括《办公室》。还有凯特·弗兰纳里，非常感谢你发来的音频剪辑。我问凯特
was there anything I could share. And she said, will you tell them all that I'm just so tickled that I merited Palmer has a Funko Pop? I love that. You can see what Kate's up to at the real Kate Flannery on Instagram. And also thank you to Justin Spitzer. And of course, Kintopedia for helping us answer all those fan questions. Thanks, guys. Yes, and Phil Shea. I reach out to these guys all the time and they always come through for me. We couldn't do the podcast without them, just like we couldn't make the show without them. That's right. And you guys, and Sam and Cody. Love you all. Have a great week and we'll see you next time. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies. Office Ladies is produced by Earwolf,
有没有什么我可以分享的。她说，你能不能告诉大家，梅雷迪思·帕尔默竟然能有一个Funko Pop玩偶，这让我觉得太有趣了。你可以通过Instagram上的“真实的凯特·弗兰纳里”（the real Kate Flannery）了解凯特最近在忙什么。还要感谢贾斯汀·斯皮策（Justin Spitzer）。当然，还有Kintopedia帮我们回答了所有这些粉丝提问。谢谢你们，伙计们。是的，还有菲尔·谢伊（Phil Shea）。我经常联系这些人，他们总是能帮到我。没有他们，我们就做不出这个播客，就像没有他们我们就拍不出这部剧一样。没错。还有你们，以及萨姆和科迪。爱你们所有人。祝大家有个美好的一周，我们下期再见。感谢收听《办公室女士》。《办公室女士》由Earwolf制作，
Jenna Fisher and Angela Kinsey. Our producer is Cody Fisher. Our sound engineer is Sam Kiefer. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
珍娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金西。我们的制作人是科迪·费舍尔。我们的音频工程师是萨姆·基弗。本集暂无评论。点击剧本中的任意句子即可留下评论。